step number one is cut out negativity
just cut out the people who don't serve
you sometimes those are friends that
you've had from kindergarten or high
school or university you're in the
Friendship out of convenience now
there's a lot of people who you might
need to let go of you might need to just
let them go They don't serve you anymore
you've walked your parallel path
together and now they've gone out well
they probably just stayed here while
you've gone out here they don't serve
you anymore and it doesn't mean you have
to be a mean person or cold or rude
you're just not on the same path anymore
and a lot of people fight that because
you're worried about finding new friends
or being around new people and so you
stick with these people who don't serve
you anymore and that's a mistake because
they're keeping you where you're at
because their negativity they're
complaining their unwillingness to
change their pessimism their laziness
they're not chasing down goals that
becomes toxic even if you're trying to
be a beacon even if you're trying to be
the person who pulls everybody up if all
you're doing is trying to pull other
people up and there's nothing pulling
you up you're going to be limited for
life need motivation watch a top 10 with
believe Nation hey it's Evan Carmichael
and I make these videos because when I
started my first business I really
struggled to believe myself I was making
300 bucks a month and quit on my
business partner and the thing that
saved me was watching the stories of
successful entrepreneurs they gave me
strategies as well as hope and belief
that just maybe I could do it myself as
well and I hope that this video here
today helps you get a little bit more
belief in yourself because isolate the
videos for myself today too so today
let's learn from me and my team's take
on my top 10 rules for success enjoy
when I went to the Tony Robbins event
the second one where he invited me to
come as his guest
at the end of the first day or second
day you're asked to go do a fire walk
and the whole idea is to do something
scary well I went home to my Airbnb at
the time and and I did the scary thing I
didn't I skipped the fire walk at Tony's
event to go home and do the real fire
walk which was letting go of some people
that that I had been around for in some
cases a decade plus that this doesn't
serve me anymore I'm I'm doing this just
out of convenience instead of something
that's actually helping me grow and so I
need to shed this skin so that I can be
reborn like this is new skin none of you
that's trying to grow
right you're trying to become a
butterfly
but you're forced to stay a caterpillar
you don't want that so you gotta let go
of the negativity sometimes that might
be family and with family maybe maybe
you should cut out some of your family
members from your life maybe maybe
that's that sounds drastic but maybe you
should a less drastic version of that is
just don't talk about some things limit
access if you know that career talk is
always going to cause problems with your
family then don't talk about your career
say I don't I'm not talking about that
and stand up for yourself
at what point is this your life this is
your life your parents your the people
around you they love you they want you
to have success they just they're from a
different era they're a different
generation they don't know what's even
possible right now
what they did if you're 21 their life at
21 was totally different your parents
life when they were your age was totally
different
they don't understand what's available
right now and so even though their
messages is out of love likely like your
parents probably love you
they just don't understand what's
possible
and you can't blame them
this is your fault now you need to
accept responsibility for where you're
at and limit the conversations limit
exposure cut out the negativity from
your life it's really hard for a seed to
grow when it's in a toxic waste dump
and that becomes a choice you know a
seed where it gets planted doesn't
really get the choice of where it gets
planted but you you get to choose you
get to change your environment so choose
powerfully and cut out the negativity
from your life rule number two is push
through hardships it's never too late to
get started it's never too late to say
yes it's never too late to start to
chase down your dreams the thing that
you got inside you it's never too late
we create these stories for ourselves as
I am too old to get started I am to acts
like fill in a blank of whatever excuse
you've got for not taking action
[Music]
it's just a story
you're just afraid and the only thing
you're missing is momentum
it's never too late
I remember when I started my business I
thought I was too young you know
I was 19 years old I was telling the
people who
were experts in science and I sucked at
science and they were two to three times
my age and I had phds and I thought I
was too young they'd never take me
seriously and that was one of the things
that really held back the growth of my
business was
just my limiting belief that I was too
young
and I talked to people all the time and
you have people who say they're too
young
and then instantly they become too old
like but when are you over the right age
you know you're too young to do it then
you're too old to do it when were you
actually ever the right age when have
you ever said you know what I'm the
right age to do this thing
right we never we never do that it's
always just the fear talking
and so you have to step up you have to
step out you have to say yes
and you have to get started people ask
me all the time is it too late to get
started on YouTube I was at a conference
I was speaking at this weekend and
is it too late Evan is it too did I miss
the boat
kidding me
first off YouTube is growing like crazy
second the the education on YouTube is
still pretty low there's so many people
going and there's still so few people
who are creating good quality education
look at whatever field you're in it's
probably even less
and third even if YouTube does go away
at some point
there's gonna be something else
people's attention is not going offline
anytime soon it's only going to increase
if YouTube goes away something else will
will come up and your ability to speak a
message to a camera is a skill set that
will serve you for life of course it's
not too late
it's just your fear talking
your big dreams and big goals and big
Ambitions are possible
there's so few worlds where it actually
is too late right and like if you're 70
years old and you want to play you know
in the NBA Athletics is the easy one to
go to then that's it's too late you know
you're not going to go you're not going
to be a professional NBA player sorry
but could you be involved in the world
of could you start a great podcast
around it a YouTube channel around it or
be an agent or like infinite number of
things in that world of course and
chances are most of your goals dreams
things that you want to do
are not tied to anything physical where
there's going to be a significant
decline right like what are the things
what do you want to do what are your
goals it's people who have done it at a
much older age than you
so how do we unlock it how do we start
to make
that momentum actually happen in your
life step number one
get really clear on what you want
what do you want what are your goals
what do you what do you want to do
what's the voice inside your head that
is telling you I wish I could do this
thing I really want to do this thing
right like getting really clear because
I meet a lot of entrepreneurs and you
know that you're capable of more and you
know you want to have a bigger impact
and you know that
that you don't want to stay stuck here
but you don't know what the thing looks
like you know it's not as clear of what
you want to do you just know that you're
stuck and you're capable of more
well you definitely don't have the whole
thing planned out but what's the next
step
just getting clear on what you want the
next step to be
can make a big big big big big big big
difference
because it gives you some clarity
whether it's even the perfect I mean
it's not going to be the perfect step
don't worry about being the perfect step
it probably won't be the right the right
step it's a step
and in taking a step you learn a lot and
you make a lot of mistakes you make a
ton of mistakes and you figure things
out I remember when I first got my phone
I was recording and I I did this video
and I was I was so proud of the video
and then I realized I captured the whole
thing in slow motion mode
the audio was terrible you can't use it
I couldn't use it like oh it was so good
slow motion mode you just you're gonna
make mistakes at the beginning that's
okay but what's the next step getting
some clarity over what that next step
should be is really important part two
is then go get some Heroes
it could be a mentor who you can
actually talk to and learn from but
Heroes
and when I say Heroes I mean people
who've done the thing that you want to
do
whenever I feel less than whenever I
feel like I can't do it whenever I feel
not good enough I Look to people who
have done it
and I realized that they have done it
with less resources less money less time
less
skills and what I have right now Your
Heroes the people who you love look up
to respect the most they did it they
accomplished with less than what you
have right now
and if they can do it you can do it too
and the whole point of that is a push to
start taking action it's not to say oh
well I suck I can never be Oprah Winfrey
or whoever go look at Oprah's story and
see where she came from and see how how
poor she was and see what her upbringing
was and imagine being Oprah imagine
having a terrible upbringing uh you know
being raped early on having tons of
violence in the family
bouncing from home to home
being so poor that she couldn't afford
clothes and her grandmother would so
address for her out of a potato bag like
imagine you're going to school in a
potato bag
that your grandmother sewed together
because you didn't have enough money to
actually get real close
can you imagine
how bad is your life compared to that
how bad was your upbringing compared to
that
right to go from where she started to
where she's at
what's your excuse
and again it's not meant to be a
negative like oh you're right I'm so
hard on myself I suck no it's more like
well that's what's possible
as soon as you get over the store you're
telling yourself that's what's possible
if she could do it
from that upbringing why can't you why
can't I
and anytime I feel like I can't do it
that that's what I default back to it's
like look at your Heroes look at where
they started look at where they came
from and chances are Your Heroes already
started with less than what you already
have right now and so surrounding
yourself with them
can give you the hope and the feeling
like it is possible if you feel like
you're too old for something then
surround yourself with entrepreneurs who
started who are way older than you
look at people who have started and they
started I don't know how old you are you
know people say I I'm 24 years old is it
too late to get started
but on every age people feel it's too
late
so surround yourself with the stories of
people who started when they're older
gives you the inspiration to go to make
to create
Island number three is come back to
service think about service think about
who you're doing this for this is this
is bigger than you it's not just about
you
so who are you gonna help
whenever it's just about you whenever
it's you're doing something for just
selfish reasons
you'll never put in the same amount of
work as if you feel like you're
responsible to somebody else this is
where a lot of entrepreneurs struggle in
starting their own business because when
you had a job you had a boss and your
boss would tell you what to do if you
didn't show up to a meeting you'd be in
trouble you know so you'd show up for
other people but you don't show up for
yourself
we just won't show up for ourselves as
much people show up for other people so
the way to hack it is to feel like what
you're doing is actually serving other
people
and if you're an entrepreneur land you
can think about the customers you're
going to serve the people who will
consume your content or buy your
products or service and the life
changing impact that you're going to
have and feel it and connect to that if
you don't have a business yet or that's
not your ambition just think about your
message to your kids
think about the message to your family
think about the message of the people
around you is your message to your kids
current or future
you know what it's too late
you when you get an idea just tell
yourself that you can't do it
you know is that going to be your
message to your of course not
but it's your message to yourself
and the people closest to you will model
much more what you do
your actions your beliefs more than what
you say
you could tell them believe in yourself
you're not it's not too late go ahead go
do it you can make this happen but when
they see you sitting on the sidelines
telling yourself that you're too old and
you can't do it that's the behavior
they're going to model
so if you're not going to do it for
yourself
that's not enough of a oomph to get you
out of the bed and actually creating
your thing then think about who you're
serving today
think about the people you're going to
help
people who by you showing up is going to
have an impact on their lives
it's not too late to start
it's never too late to start
your life
could be so different
if you woke up and started doing a thing
that was in your heart it's not going to
work out at the beginning you're going
to have a lot of failures you're going
to have a lot of laughs you're going to
have a lot of struggles as you get going
but holy cow your life can be
dramatically different one year two
years five years from today
if you just decided you know what
I'm just tired of staying stuck
I'm tired of coming up with excuses
I'm tired of playing small
it's time
I need this for myself
I need this for my family
I need this for the people who I'm going
to serve and help
it's time
time
it's your time
let's see what you can make rule number
three is start saying yes the starting
point to find your passion is to say yes
more
we are in the no business new idea comes
oh no I can't do that new opportunity
arises you get invited no no someone
like me can't do this we're constantly
saying no no no no no no no no no no no
you'll never find your passion by saying
no it's actually the opposite you got to
say yes you got to say yes to
Opportunities you got to say yes to
ideas you got to say yes to that thing
that comes into your head that maybe you
can go off and do yes I'm gonna try I'm
going to be willing to suck I'm going to
be willing for it not to work out but
I'm gonna try because we judge things
before we've been trying I like to say
how do you know what your favorite food
is well you know by by trying you know
by tasting a whole bunch of different
foods until you find the one that you
love like wow that's my favorite food
work most people they don't try enough
Foods if you think about sushi
did I use as an example I uh wrote off
sushi at the beginning like that sounds
nasty I mean like not judging you want
to eat it awesome but it sounds gross
it's raw fish
wrapped in seaweed with some rice and
fish eggs that sounds gross right for
someone who's not used to it
Italian you know Western diet that
sounds gross
and you're going to dip it in soy sauce
and hot mustard right but you know what
I'm just gonna try it you know what this
is really good
it tastes so good all right now I love
sushi so she's so she's got to be in my
top five favorite foods but we judge
things and we're doing that not just
with Foods we're doing that with people
we're doing that with business ideas
we're doing that with opportunities I
look at YouTube and how long it took me
holy cow how long it took me to get
momentum
because I was judging it
not judging a platform but judging
myself that someone like me can't do it
because I'm introverted because I'm shy
because only people with a big ego get
in front of a camera all of these things
I was just in a no business I would say
no I was saying no I was saying no I was
saying no and listen I I'm not perfect I
still say no on things that I'm trying
to get better at
if you haven't found the thing that
you're passionate about that excites you
that drives you that pushes you forward
you're not going to find it sitting on
the couch judging yourself and doing the
same things that you have been doing
right you do the exact same things you
have been doing for the past year your
life doesn't change in the next year
right you gotta explore got to say yes
and that takes courage and that takes
jumping through some discomfort and it
just says the ability to say yes on
things
so I was recently hanging out with Tom
bill you and Dave Hollis and a bunch of
friends in in Napa in my biggest
takeaway
was I want to move faster on things I
want to move faster on new things it's
so easy to get locked into what you're
currently doing you know what I need to
move faster on things and so I came home
and I went faster on learning crypto I
went faster on learning about life
insurance and investing I went faster on
creating my Discord server I went faster
on all the ideas that I had it's like
okay imperfect start just build momentum
and go and now Discord has been a big
part of my daily routine I've adjusted
my entire
schedule to start my day in Discord I
went from spending zero time on Discord
not understanding what it was not
understanding a little the graphics and
what mods did and all the roles and all
of the stuff the lingo and all of the
terminology language I didn't know any
of it
to now I spend
the first chunk of my time every morning
on Discord
if you want to join us it's free Evan
carmichael.biz come come and come and
join in it's such a great way to start
my day because I love the community
because I love connecting with people
when I when I go to events my favorite
thing is to hang out in the hallway and
talk to people and that's basically what
Discord is you get to hang out in the
hallway and talk to people and help them
and spread love and we've so many
amazing people
and the point of that is I
now have this new thing in my calendar
that I love and I look forward to it's
like I can't wait to go back and say hi
to everybody even though I'm shy and
introverted it feels weird but a month
ago I wasn't doing it at all and it
could have easily been the thing that I
said no to that I said you know I'm so
busy I have YouTube and I have I have my
other channels and I have my team and I
have right all the stories we tell
ourselves as to why we can't do it it's
being in the no business how do you know
until you try
how do you know if your great idea is
great unless you try or if it sucks
unless you try I think if you're gonna
love something unless you try how do you
know if you're gonna love that person
unless you try don't know until you try
so so what are some practical steps okay
number one when you get an idea that
comes into your head trust it
I wish I could X
oh I've got this cool idea for me to why
do it just trust that the idea is a good
idea trust that it's good it's for you
it's meant for you especially if you're
in a positive environment you're
watching a video like this or you're
right in the van you're talking to
somebody and you have positive vibes
it's like I want to go make this trust
that that idea is good get out of the no
business and just start building some
immediate momentum so trust that good
ideas flow through you good ideas great
ideas extraordinary ideas flow through
you trust that
trust that and do something about it
because we don't want to wait another
year and another year and another year
and you're still sitting on these ideas
because someone like you can't do it
right so one trust that great ideas flow
through you and do something about it
two tied in the service right your
purpose comes from your pain so whatever
you struggle the most with is what you
want to help other people through so tie
that to service your passion is
something that you'll love helping other
people with so it's not just about you
if it's if your own passion that's just
a hobby right something you love doing
for yourself great that's just a hobby
but ultimately we all want to feel
important we all want to feel not from
an egotistical point of view from a it's
wired into us from a human point of view
we want to feel like we matter we want
to feel like we're going to do something
today that will have an impact on other
people we are connected to each other
and so your your passion will tie into
your purpose your purpose comes in your
pain whatever you struggle the most with
is what you want to help other people
through
so inside of that
helping the you from five years ago or
ten years ago what do you need to do
what are some of the the steps that you
can sit there and help the you from five
years ago
that will be a part of your passion to
wake up and feel like I'm doing this
that's fun
that's exciting for me it doesn't feel
like work but it's also having an impact
it has to tie to service it has to if
you wanted to fill you up for the rest
of your life it has to tie to service
that it's not just this one you know
short timeline thing just to help you
feel good it has to help other people
feel good as well somehow so number one
is trust a great ideas flow through you
two tie it to service you feel like
you're helping other people it's going
to make a big big difference and then
number three
is pay attention to things that make you
scared
pay attention to things that make you
scared and teach yourself that you do
difficult things so a lot of times
an idea might come to you or somebody
might suggest something for you and the
immediate thing that comes to mind is
this is difficult or your heart's beaten
I called the boom boom boom test where
your heart's going boom boom boom boom
boom boom boom because you're nervous
because you're you're afraid of doing
that thing
often your your next amazing passions on
the other side of all those things that
you're afraid of
because you're afraid that it's not
going to work or you're afraid that it's
going to disappoint people you're afraid
that it will work you're afraid of
you're afraid of failure and you're
afraid of success you're afraid of
judgment you're afraid of rejection
you're afraid you're afraid you're
afraid you're afraid you're afraid
you're afraid
but you don't find your passion by
staying afraid
find it by saying yes
so the things that are making you afraid
the things that make your heart go boom
boom boom boom boom boom boom boom like
that
trust him
try it
expect it to suck expect not to get any
results
expect your first shot to miss that's
okay what's more important than if you
got the result is that you enjoy the
process
did you have fun doing it are you
excited let's go back and do it again
you've got
a great gift inside you
you know you're capable of more you know
you want to serve you know you want to
help you know that you don't want to
stay stuck that's not that your life
sucks right now but if you want to you
want it to be more full you want to be
more Rich you want to be in a different
spot in one year from today and that
happens by tapping into the thing that
you're passionate about
the number one rule for Success we love
the work you love the process of doing
the thing that you're doing every day
and you get that by getting out of the
no business
stop telling yourself that you can't
stop telling yourself no stop telling
yourself that someone like you can't do
it and instead flip it to say yes I'm
gonna try rule number four is raise your
environment your environment is keeping
you where you are your environment has
been perfectly designed to keep you
exactly where you are right now the
people you listen to the media that you
consume the habits that you do daily all
of them all of them are designed to keep
you exactly where you are so if you want
to raise your game if you want to raise
your life you need to raise your
environment I've changed a lot over the
course of having this YouTube channel
the people who've known me the best and
the longest especially in the past two
to three years have said Evan you've
changed a lot for the better you've
evolved you're more confident you have
more more Poise you're a better speaker
you you're pushing the boundaries more
you've changed what happened how do I
get that for myself right people wanted
it as whenever you are off growing and
learning and evolving other people they
want it they want a taste of it they
want to do it too because we are not
designed to just photocopy Our Lives
over and over and over again so how did
I get it I paid more attention to my
environment I paid more attention to my
daily routines I paid more attention to
the people that I hang around with
it's important so looking at my physical
environment right look at the look at
this office look at the people behind me
this all means something to me looking
at the new design that I've had here
below putting things like my neck braces
it's down below you can't really see it
but this inspires me I walk into this
every day
my YouTube videos the channel I create
for myself
the the people that I profile I'm
learning from I feel like I have garyvee
in my head I have Oprah Winfrey in my
ear I've got Elon Musk tell me what to
do pushing me to try to get better I
hear these people talking about you have
to be courageous you have to be bold you
have to believe in yourself more and
when I feel myself being nervous about
something boom boom boom boom boom it's
a push that I have to do it
and so I've designed my life I've
designed my environment to help push me
to get to the next step
and it's it's scary and it should be
where am I going next I don't know I'm
still a work in progress but the more
that you are around people who push you
who make you better who make you want to
do more who pull you up to their level
guess what the more you're gonna get
there the alternative is you're stuck
where you are you stick with your
friends you stick with the media you
consume you stick with the habits that
you have and listen if you love your
life awesome if you're good then you're
good then then
don't change anything but if you're not
happy with where you're at if you know
you're capable of more especially for
the entrepreneurs you know you're
capable of more you know you have a gift
you know you're a genius you know what's
in here needs to get out there can have
a huge impact and help a lot of people
if you feel like that's you then you
need to make a drastic change to your
environment
you need to change it because everything
you're doing right now is keeping you on
the path that you're on maybe there's
been some growth if you look at who you
were five years ago compared to now
you've grown if you're watching this
channel you've grown right you've made
some changes but is it drastic enough
like are you proud of where you're at
look at where you've come from in the
past year two years five years are you
proud of where you're at and are you
comfortable with that same level of
growth for the next five years if not if
you think I want more I want to help
faster I want to have a bigger impact
faster quicker then the fastest way to
do it is to change your environment also
to make sure you're actually taking
action after watching this video I've
designed a special free worksheet just
for this video the worksheet will
highlight all the Lessons Learned in
this video as well as pull out our three
favorite learnings and quotes that will
inspire you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet design specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business I'll see you
there rule number five is stop doing
everything alone stop trying to do this
alone
if you've got a big idea inside you you
can't do this alone you need people
around you to help you to encourage you
to support you to cover your weaknesses
to help you actually go off and
accomplish that big dream of yours this
is one of the biggest things that I
think holds people back holds
entrepreneurs back
is you're probably decently good at the
thing that you want to do
you know you've had some experience or
you've gone and learned and figured it
out and you still to get better as you
keep practicing keep going and doing
more and maybe at some point you even
did try to hire somebody maybe at some
point you did try to bring somebody on
and it didn't work out
didn't work out
and here's where everybody makes the
mistake you Retreat and go back to say
you know what it was just a lot faster
when I did it myself does that happen
has that happened to you ever been there
you hired somebody you thought I'm gonna
do this I'm gonna hire somebody you do
it it doesn't work out
and then you go back to say I'm just
going to do this all myself no no no no
no no that is not the answer
that is not the answer that's like if
you go on one date and it doesn't work
out now you're never gonna go on another
date again you're never gonna be married
right that doesn't make sense
that doesn't make sense you're living in
fear as opposed to actually trying to
build the thing that you're capable of
building
here's what happens
when you first hire somebody you don't
know what you're doing
right it's like when you first did
anything you don't know what you're
doing
so why do you expect to be great at
picking the right person and then
treating them well then managing them
well you don't know what you're doing
there's a guy in my movement makers who
joined my Discord as well
and he was talking about how he had I
hired his second video editor and it
didn't work out
and he had to let the person go so he's
hired two video editors both of them
couldn't get his style
and he had to let them go and he's going
back to editing everything himself now
as a short-term solution great like
stuff has to get up videos have to be
edited get them out
but don't stop searching
just because you had two failed hires
right like if you tomorrow are editing
videos awesome but if you next year are
still editing your videos not awesome
nope not awesome not anymore right this
is how we start to raise our standards
and so the first two people that you
hired weren't good fits great keep
searching keep looking
your perfect fit is out there and as you
go through some people and go through
the process you'll get better at
actually finding the right person
you know you'll get better at it don't
judge yourself that say well I suck at
this I can't hire I'm never going to
find the person it's just faster to do
it myself right there's that old
expression you can go fast by yourself
but you go far with the team
you have to build a team so let's talk
about how to do it okay let's stop let's
talk about steps practical steps
building the team creating the culture
uh someone who now has 37 people on the
team I'm not I'm not Jeff Bezos with uh
I don't know how many thousands of
people are on his team but 37 on our
team right now how do you how do you go
from starting up to that step number one
is figure out what is the most important
skill
that you need that has to get done in
the business that you suck at
okay and you don't want to get better at
what do you suck at that has to get done
in the business not something that you
know maybe it's a nice to have it like
it has to get done in the business you
suck at it and not just you suck at it
right now you just you never want to get
better at it you're just not interested
in it some people love this thing and
you hate it and you never want to get
better at it what is that thing
that's the first person you need to
bring on into your business it could be
part-time it it I it definitely should
not be a full-time person
here's why
one you don't know how to hire yet
two it's going to take you too long to
be able to save up the money to hire
somebody full-time and three you're not
used to managing people
so you want a part-time person when I
first started I had interns I had
interns from high school who were
helping me do a lot of the things that I
need to get done and it was part of
their school credit Nina is back
I did foreign language interns so people
came to Toronto as part of their
education
being from a different country learning
English and getting job experience
when you find people I've had people
volunteer to join I've had people work
one hour a day to join right just like
you need to start getting some people
involved because
it makes you feel like you're not alone
doing this which is a big deal
and it also starts building some
traction you know it starts finally
getting some of the things off your
plate that you wish didn't exist anymore
and suddenly now they don't because
someone else is taking care of it right
step number two is you have to start
asking for help this is a big problem
for a lot of entrepreneurs you're afraid
to ask for help at the startup phase
especially
well some what if they steal my idea
it's one of the most common questions we
ever felt that what if what if I tell
somebody my idea and they steal it they
go with it
well
it's possible
it's possible very low possibility most
people are are running their own
business the amount of people have come
to me and say Evan uh I'd love your help
on this but but I need you to sign this
NDA non-disclosure agreement it's like I
don't care about your idea
I have my own business to run I've got
my own channels my own team my own
things to worry about I'm not gonna they
think the top priority is you have some
great idea that I'm going to then take
and run with that that's now my new
business plan no and now you missed the
chance to actually get some feedback and
help
so you have to share your ID the idea
alone is not enough it's the execution
it really matters
so it's not just the idea that you've
got it's can you be the one to go off
and create it to make it to to birth it
to turn it into reality and
speed matters
have you ever seen anybody with your
idea right air quotes your idea
go off and win while you were still
sitting on the sidelines
right that seen it happen so many times
have so many people message me about it
it's like I had this idea three years
ago and I didn't do it and now here's
this person off making millions off of
it well what's the difference chances
are they had less heart than you less
less
of a drive to do good less caring than
you so why are they winning well because
they started and they asked for help
and you were trying to do it all by
yourself
so you have to share your idea you have
to recruit people on board you have to
ask for help because those people can
make the difference between you actually
following through
on your goals
I then step three is you have to Mentor
the people on your team you have to care
about them as humans the next big
mistake a lot of entrepreneurs make when
they're when they're hiring is okay this
person's gonna come on they're going to
take all the stuff off my plate so I can
focus on being the CEO and everything's
gonna be great
and that's a nice Theory
um you know that that kind of happens
but what you want to think about is
this is a human working with you
you know this is a human who's got goals
and their own Ambitions and their own
dreams and your job should be to help
them grow as a human that they should be
better
as a person by spending time with you by
being around you
and by being in your company
most people treat people like robots
they treat them like monkeys okay get
this done get that done perfect gone you
know you made you made my life easier
awesome that's what you're hired to do
go do your job
where where
people make the mistake of is one not
giving enough training at the beginning
like did you actually set somebody up
for success and the two just not caring
about them enough as a human
I'm actually starting to find it harder
as I grow it was a lot easier when I had
one to five people on the team but at 37
I don't know what everybody's up to I
don't remember everybody's projects I'm
not in as much of the day-to-day of what
they're doing I find it hard to balance
everybody's
goals and just stay on top of of their
life and I don't know what it's going to
look like when we're at 50 people or 75
people or 100 people I don't know what
that process looks like I'm figuring out
you know what I gotta ask for help as I
grow
but two of the things that I've done
that have worked out pretty well
the first is
I dedicate Mondays to team days
so I have an entire day
of the week that's dedicated to team
and so
I'm spending that day on Zoom calls or
in person meeting with Team asking them
what's going on helping them with their
projects and just spending time with
them and so people know that on Mondays
when they save all their stuff and talk
to me about it
scheduling in time for Team matters so I
have different things for different days
of the week today's a Tuesday because
I'm recording so recording is Tuesday
but yesterday was Monday and and I was
spending the whole time basically on
Zoom calls with team
the second thing that I'll do is uh is a
quarterly check-in with people and we
don't even talk about the business
you should do it on a Sunday so it's not
a work day it's a Sunday morning coffee
every Sunday I'm spending with someone
on my team
Sunday morning I grab my coffee they
grab whatever drink they want and we do
a session together and we will touch on
business we'll touch on what they're
doing but not operationally focused not
hey you didn't get this thing done or
hey how are we doing on this project
it's more like where do you want to go
with your life
what are you curious about what are you
love and about the work that you're
doing here how can I help you get to the
next step what else are you curious
about what are your other goals just
just a life conversation
and you'd be surprised that
what comes out
and most people all they all they really
need is just somebody to listen to them
and care
and sometimes action happens immediately
after sometimes it happens you know the
next month or the next quarter but when
you know the hopes the goals the dreams
the Ambitions of the people on your team
the people around you it allows you to
be a much better and much more effective
leader
so we took you to this the process of
startup zero you know Team all the way
to now how do you manage you know your
first 37 at least people in your company
but underpinning all of this is
the understanding that you can't do this
alone rule number six is take action if
you're not growing you're not happy
humans who want to grow you want to grow
you want to feel like you've learned
something you're getting better you're
improving you're giving back you're
serving you you don't want to stay stuck
we don't want to stay stuck no human
wants to stay stuck you do not want to
stay stuck if if I talk about hey in one
year you're going to be in the exact
same spot as you are right now you're
going to have the same knowledge that
you're going to have the same Financial
wherewithal you're going to have the
same mindset you're going to be exactly
the same in one year
that's not happiness nobody wants that
you want to feel like you're learning
you're growing you're getting better
you're improving we all we all want to
feel like we are growing the challenge
is growing is scary
growing requires stretching the comfort
zone how many posts do we have to see
about stepping outside the comfort zone
right you know it
but it's an intellectual knowing and not
enough of actual doing because you're
afraid
and this is a big challenge for
entrepreneurs because you know you're
capable of more and you know you've got
a big mission and you know you've got a
big dream you know that you want to do
more
but you're afraid of that thing
and the fear puts on the brakes
so you've got I'm in my car right now
you've got your feet on the gas and a
break at the same time what happens when
you have your feet on the gas and a
break at the same time nothing you don't
move you know you're gonna end up
spinning your wheels
gas and a break at the same time the gas
is your
desire to grow and learn and know what
you can make and what you can create and
the life you want to build for yourself
and your family and the impact you want
to have and the lives that you're going
to touch right it's exciting it's
exciting to think about everything you
can make it's so amazing
and then because we're afraid
no break no not happening no and so what
we end up doing is just watching a bunch
of content or reading a bunch of books
or going to a bunch of seminars and
having these moments of
breakthrough and wisdom and maybe tiny
bit of momentum and then immediately the
brakes come back on again
it's not even we blame haters and we
bring blame our family it's not even the
people around us it's you it's the voice
inside your own head telling you not to
do it that you can't do it
it's a sustained momentum that's missing
you want to grow and if you're not happy
it's because you're not growing
so how do we do it how do we how do we
start the Breakthrough how do we start
to get that actual momentum and the
growth so that you don't look back on
the life that you have or the past year
that's been in and hate it and hate
yourself because that's where we get
stuck right it's like hey I wasted the
past two years I knew I wanted to do it
and I wasted has that happened to you
you ever felt like that I wasted the
past years of my life I suck and we just
beat ourselves up that's not the point
the point of this is not to beat
ourselves up the point is to is to use
the potential fear of regret as as a
driving force to move forward okay so
how do we do how do we start getting
into action mode how do we start
listening to our intuition how do we
start building the momentum that we need
to get the growth in our lives to build
a better life for ourselves and the
people around us
one is get inspired you are the product
of your environment we've talked a lot
about that you are the average of the
five people you hang out with right
people have said that over and over and
over again so how do you elevate your
environment so that you can be more
inspired
I do it through my content
I do it by being around Dave Hollis and
Brendan burchard and Tony Robbins and
Oprah and all the people that I profile
on my channel I do I'm around them they
inspire me I've had the fortune to meet
some of them to to be able to call them
but but a one-off call isn't enough like
you need a daily just like you need to
brush your teeth for your dental hygiene
you need you need inspiration hygiene
you need mental hygiene by being around
the people who inspire you it's why I
make so many videos and hopefully
there's something that that inspires you
it's the idea of this channel like why
to start your day with some inspiration
to help you get going to give you the
courage to say yes
so what makes you come alive who are the
people who you want to spend more time
with and find a way to do it whether
it's a real human that you can go and
have coffee with or talk to or if it's
online
you know again most of my Inspirations
come from online from my own videos I
make them for me and then I share them
with you and thankfully you guys like
them so we can we can invest in team
continue building more content out but
who are the people that make you come
alive just the way they speak the way
they talk it just connects with you and
it makes you want to do more
you know not in a bad way like I suck I
should have done better but in a in a
positive way forward like I want to show
up better today for myself and the
people around me who makes you feel like
that and then surround yourself with
them and if it's me I'm honored to be a
part of your journey and if it's
somebody else a lot of people discover
people through my channels like hey I
discovered Dave Hollis or garyvee or
Tony Robbins through your channel thank
you I don't watch as much of your
content anymore but I watch them a lot
they're great as long as you're getting
what you need that's that's the whole
point so step number one is you have to
be inspired okay how do we start getting
the growth Be Inspired build it into
your daily routine being if you were
inspired every day
not hoping things happen not hoping
somebody sends you a message right
that's not going to happen but you you
manufacture it you create it because you
know being around these people inspire
you if you did that then you got
inspired every day your life will be
dramatically different I promise you
step number two is immediate momentum
immediate immediate immediate immediate
momentum you want growth immediate
momentum you get that idea you get that
inspired
voice coming into your head it's going
to say hey Evan
Evan this hey launch this video hey sign
up for Discord hey get it to nfts hey
like whatever the thing is whatever the
voice that comes to you when you feel
inspired that's the right voice for you
that is guiding you in the right
direction listen to it
listen to it and take some kind of
immediate momentum
I was talking to somebody inside my
Discord today
asking him about his nft projects is I
might have my nft project uh he wanted
to start his and and it's just a lot of
overthinking it's like well I don't know
I don't know how to do the SMART
contracts and I don't know what kind of
value to add I don't know I've got this
big plan for how everybody can earn a
share of what what this project makes
and and I don't know how the mechanics
of a lot works like dude that is such a
big Vision it's great
but what's the immediate momentum you
can take today
to start to learn about it
it's like yeah I'm overthinking it
launch
create go and you'll learn more about
actually doing and by trying to
overthink your way through every step
the overthinking is just fear talking
so you've got great ideas momentum guys
momentum immediate momentum
what's the thing like that first step is
the hardest step filming the first video
is the hardest step creating the first
page of your book is the hardest step
it's the hardest step is the first step
so just take that step give yourself the
permission to suck and just make that
first step happen immediate momentum so
number one get inspired too immediate
momentum and then three
create a calendar
that maps to your ambitions so the
immediate momentum is great now we need
to sustain it well sustain momentum
comes from Habits and habits come from
what's in your calendar if you hope that
you have time in your calendar to make
something happen it's never going to
happen right it just it just won't
I'm filming this on my YouTube day once
once a week I have a day that I dedicate
to filming videos and if I didn't have
it in my calendar it wouldn't happen if
I waited till I was always inspired it
wouldn't happen
there's a call happen later on today and
somebody asked me if I was going to join
the cause it will depends on depends on
how well my videos go I'm filming videos
today it's blocked off I block the whole
day off and sometimes it flows and I'm
just banging out videos like oh my gosh
this is such a great Vibe I'm in let's
go and sometimes it's more of a grind
where I have to I have to manufacture it
I gotta I gotta build it inside myself
before I can make the videos so
sometimes it comes up really quickly and
sometimes it takes more time but I have
the whole day planned to do it
and if I didn't have that date planned I
wouldn't make nearly as many videos
you know
so it can start with an inspiration
right you go through the three steps it
starts with inspiration I'm gonna make
videos you know I'm going to make some
content right if that's you great you
got ins that's that idea came to you yes
we're in the yes business now we're not
in the no business anymore yes we're
gonna do that great set number two
immediate momentum the best thing you
can do is film a video today
film a video today that's all you need
to do
but what camera and what microphone and
what gear and when am I going to talk
don't
overthink it I'm sitting in my car on my
cell phone well Nina is at Costco you
can't really see it Nina's shopping at
Costco
and I'm filming off my cell phone
go immediate momentum
and then three
we've made our first video great now
when's the next one going to come out
you create a calendar for it you block
off some time once a week once a month
whatever it is put in your calendar this
is when I'm going to be making more
content
you get inspired
you take immediate momentum
I mean you put it in your calendar so
that momentum becomes a sustainable
habit
this is how you grow
because you want to grow because growth
is important
growth will lead to happiness if you
felt like the next year is going to
matter that you're going to grow as a
human you're going to grow in your in
your finances you're going to grow in
your mindset you're going to grow in
your knowledge set you're going to grow
in your ability to serve you're going to
grow in the impact that you're going to
have if you could actually feel like I'm
going to grow a lot this year
then actually execute on it
where would you need to be in a year for
you to look back and say I'm proud of
myself
maybe you're proud of yourself for the
past year you know maybe you're
incredibly proud of yourself or maybe
you're saying that
you know what I did some things but I
could have done a lot more
use that as a fuel to make the next year
count
the growth that you have inside you
it's entirely possible when you decide
to consistently
get inspired to get medium momentum and
then schedule in the habits so that
momentum becomes sustainable rule number
seven is develop a success mindset you
have a single most important core value
and when you figure it out your entire
life changes if you feel like you're
being pulled in a million different
directions
you're walking on quicksand everybody
wants something from you you're hot and
cold you want to do something one day
and you don't the other day you have a
hard time saying no to people and to
Opportunities and you're just being
pulled in a thousand directions does
that sound familiar does it sound like
you
if that's you
you don't know what you stand for
because when you know what you stand for
all decisions become easier
I wrote two books on this your one word
and then built the serve and at the core
both of them is figuring out what what
do you stand for what is your single
most important core value and when you
can name it when you can label it when
you can get to the root of it what it
does is give you Clarity for the rest of
your life
mine is belief my one word is belief
I want to believe in myself more and I
want to spread belief to the world to
the people around me it's why I make all
these videos
I make them for myself because I need to
learn and I want to be around the best I
want to be around people who inspire me
to believe more in myself and I try to
spread that to the world
it becomes a filter through which I see
the world it becomes the filter through
which my best self operates
whenever I don't know what to do
whenever I'm given an opportunity
whenever I might be pulled in a thousand
different directions
what do I run that through as well
believe
what would the believe version of Evan
do what would he do
and then that just makes it easier
boom decision made
easier
if you look at my YouTube Channel people
say well you do all these top 10 rules
and you do all these inspiring videos
it's great why not do top 10 of the
stupidest things this person said
or top 10 reasons why not to follow this
person
if I did that if I if I went negative on
Kanye West or Donald Trump or whoever
those videos would actually do better
you know this is where it gets really
tough this is where it really comes down
to what you stand for and how much do
you stand for
because when you can get to the core of
who you are that becomes a lot easier
because
making those videos if I was to slam
people
would do better people would much rather
watch negative videos than positive
people would much rather laugh at
somebody else than educate themselves
it's just just how we always rather
watch
big brother and watch reality TV shows
and people tearing each other apart you
can't look away from a car accident or
fight on the street we have this thing
inside us where we like seeing other
people
not doing well because that's how we
feel better about ourselves when you see
somebody else struggling to see someone
else's terrible life on TV
feel better about yourself so we have
this we have this insecurity inside all
of us
and so those videos would do better or
top 10 stupidest things Kanye West has
said would would get more views would
make me more money would lead to more
subscribers would lead to all the
metrics that
that you would probably look at right
you know if I look at well what are my
goals do I want more subscribers more
views more comments more Revenue it
would help all of that
but it's anti-belief
I don't want I feel gross I don't want
to put that content up I don't want to
put up content slamming people it's not
who I am it's not what makes me come
alive
and this is where you could do it for a
short amount of time and you're going to
start to burn out because you start to
hate your life because you're doing work
that is just against who you want to be
you look at Dave Hollis he's got his one
word of Captain great so what does a
captain do
Captain goes through choppy Waters
Captain is built for the rough Seas
so if he's ever stuck thinking about
should I do this or not well what would
a captain do
and then boom answer
so figuring out your one word figuring
out that most important core value what
it does is give you a roadmap
for the rest of your life and it it
never gets old I will never stop
believing
in myself and others and wanting to
continue to inspire Dave Hollis will
never stop wanting to be the captain
and you need to figure out what yours is
because that gives you direction again
for the rest of your life
so how do we do it how do what are some
of the tactics what are some of the
tricks that you can use because I think
this is one of the most important
exercises you can ever do in your life
understanding what you stand for as a
human
it's not it's not taught you know in
schools it's not taught in textbooks
most of the people who've taught you in
schools they're not happy with the
direction of their life either right
like as you start to get older when
you're when you're a kid and you look at
your parents and adults you feel like
they got it all figured out and they
have the answers and then you realize
they have no idea what they're doing
like they're barely hanging on
themselves
the teachers who taught you about you
know life and in school they're not
happy with their own life
they haven't figured this out either
but I think it's one of the most
important things that we can learn so
again I have two books on it your one
word built to serve you want to go
deeper those are great resources but you
start with what are some of the things
that make you come alive
you know who was your favorite teacher
growing up
what movies did you love growing up what
did you love about how your parents
raised you even if you hate your parents
was there anything that you can pull out
that you loved
and what you're doing is looking at what
are some of the things that tie these
things together
so if you had the right this is the
exercise I do with people
okay tell me your favorite movie and
three words to describe it
tell me who your favorite teacher was
and three words to describe them think
about your favorite teacher growing up
favorite coach your favorite mentor
it's not because they taught you grade 8
science
right it wasn't that material they
taught you they made you feel better as
a human they taught you how to be a
better person why what did they do
I was talking to a woman yesterday
coaching her through this process we did
an Instagram live together she's part of
my movement makers program in just past
a year being in the program so we did a
live together and she wanted to go
through this exercise how do I find my
one word
and her favorite teacher growing up
wasn't a teacher but was her coach she
was a track coach and one of the things
that she loved about the track coach was
he would get in and do it with her
so whenever she was tired whenever she
wanted to quit whenever she didn't feel
good enough he wouldn't just give her
words but he would do it with her he'd
say okay
I'll do the last one with you race me
he would run alongside her
so as you think about it what what was
your favorite teacher growing up who was
it and and why write down
some descriptive keywords and what
you'll find is if you do that with who
your favorite mentors are who your
favorite teachers are what your favorite
books or videos are look at my Channel
all the people we profiled and who were
the people that you resonate with the
most if you love me what are three words
about Evan Carmichael that you love you
love Dave paulus what are three words
that describe Dave Hollis you know all
the good things that that you love that
make you feel alive and bold and
confident and serving and wanting to
help all those things are connected
but they don't feel connected this is
the problem this is the the connective
tissue work that you have to do this is
where we never learn these things the
things that you love are not just random
occurrences they're connected
when you write them down the descriptive
keywords you'll see a trend that happens
between them
so for me it's belief my favorite movie
is Seabiscuit it's about a horse that's
too small and a jockey that's too big
and a team owner that's going bankrupt
and somehow they come together find each
other and win all of these races and
it's based off a true story and they go
and beat the the well-funded you know
the team that has the perfect jockey and
the giant horse and the tons of money
and they go and they beat those guys
right so if I were to write down you
know the three words believe is on there
I might say Underdog I might say
inspiring I might say believe I would
say believe you know and then if I think
about my favorite teacher growing up
Madame Farr taught me French but I don't
even use my French like French isn't
even that valuable for the work that I
do why do I love Madame Farr well
because she believed in me because she
would meet with me once a week when I
was in my
graduating year
and
she just asked me about my life how I
was doing in school I was introverted I
was shy
you know it was harder for me to make
friends and feel like I fit in and
belonged and so for her I might put
belong I would definitely put the leave
and I might put something else maybe
care or compassion
in those meetings with her once a week
turned me from a BNC student into a
straight A student when I didn't think
that that was possible for for me to do
it because I never really gotten A's my
entire School career so
we start to look at the similarities
right that I'm far
believe you know compassion Etc
Seabiscuit Underdog believe right
there's different keywords that will
show up but what's a consistent one
believe
uh that's interesting
it's interesting this keeps coming up
what would happen if I built my whole
life around belief
what would happen if I built my business
around belief what would happen if I
created a schedule
and a calendar and habits and routines
that made me feel more belief what would
happen if I could spread that belief to
others what would happen if I brought on
team members who love believe and helped
spread believe with their skills and
talents what would happen if I had my
significant other
believe in me right what would happen
What would how much has life changed
free thing Everything Changes because
now I'm designing a life
with intent
purpose and with design
as opposed to randomly having things
experienced for me to me because
everybody's got an agenda for your time
everybody wants you to do certain things
and that's when you feel lost and being
pulled in a million different directions
you have to figure out what you stand
for I think it's the most important
thing you can do as a human what do you
stand for what's your single most
important core value
some people get it right away from the
exercises some people take some time and
you you sit on it and it becomes more
and more right or more and more wrong
but when you find it
and you get that Compass you get that
road map it's with you for the rest of
your life it makes every decision easier
it makes you live a lot more in
alignment and makes you feel like what
you're doing is important that it
matters it gives you the confidence and
the courage to the thing that you're
afraid to do to step outside your
comfort zone to build the business and
the life that you want
and ultimately to make you happy
to make you happy
and then you can spread that happiness
to others will help them believe in
themselves too rule number eight is
chase your dreams the voice inside your
head telling you that you can't do
something is not your voice
it was put there
it was planted there
it was fertilized there by the people
around you by your parents by your
teachers by your friends Growing Up by
Society it was put there think about it
when when you
were born when you were young I don't
know what your earliest memories are but
you see kids everything is possible
yeah like I'm gonna be an astronaut and
I'm going to be an architect at the same
time and you know my goal growing up I
was going to be a baseball player
play for the Toronto Blue Jays my
hometown team and I was going to be a
police officer in the off season
so be professional baseball player I
love Kelly Gruber growing up third
baseman for the Toronto Blue Jays and in
the off season
gonna be a police officer
because I love police officers you're
like everything is possible
everything is possible the kids and then
what happens
suddenly we start to get older and we
realize that things aren't that way and
we have to be safe and we have to be
practical and we have to be smart
and that message gets drilled into us
and it could be your parents it could be
your friends it could be the school
system it could be the media it could be
Society there's lots of it
think about the people who are giving
you the advice
think about the people
that's why it's so valuable think about
the people telling you that you can't do
something
and how many of those people genuinely
love their life
the people telling you you can't do
something how much of them actually love
their life not a lot
they don't
what gives them the authority
to tell you that you can't do it some
people will do it out of fear
it's love but fear right maybe your
mom's telling you you can't do something
but she loves you probably
she's telling you because she wants you
to be happy she's telling you because
she's afraid she's telling you because
if you go off and do something that
doesn't work what's going to happen to
your life she's living from a place of
insecurity right that but it's love
and some people do it because of
jealousy
they try to live their dream they took
their shot and it didn't work out and so
now nobody else around them is allowed
to succeed instead of going and taking a
second shot they spend their time trying
to tear other people down
but either way
they're not happy
they never lived their life they never
chase after their goals they never
pursued their dreams
and now they're telling you that you
can't get married most people are not
happy
look at any
survey any study and or even just think
about it think about the people saying
no in your life are they does this
person actually love their life
probably you know
so why we listen to them
and this is this is a problem because
most people don't love their lives right
and so you're surrounded by it's
everywhere it's it's in everything that
you're picking up and so it takes a
conscious effort to start to shift that
and this is why so many people when they
do learn when they do improve when
you've you've been on a personal
development personal growth Journey when
you learn something you want to go help
the people around you right the first
thing we want to do the first instinct
is to then bring it to the people around
us
because
we want the world to be better
right
so that voice is not yours that voice is
planted the mistake is seeking that it's
yours the mistake is thinking that that
insecure voice inside your head is
actually you talking it's not you
talking
that voice telling you that you suck
that you can't do this as someone like
you will never make it that's not you
that's not your real voice that is your
parents that is your school that is
society that is the media that's not
your voice that's what you've been
conditioned to believe
so how do we how do we start to change
it the goal of this video is not to be
you know giant conspiracy theory the
world's against us but it's possible
like how do you change it how do you
start to shift it well
we need to recognize one that that's not
your voice do you believe that that's
your voice because as long as you
believe that that's you
you stay small you stay stuck you stay
listening to it because you're telling
yourself that you can't do it so step
one is to recognize that that is not
actually your voice and if you can do
the deeper work to figure out well whose
is it
whose voice is that is that your parents
is that your brothers is that your
schools is that the meeting you're
consuming is that like who is it whose
voice is that and why do you still care
about listening to that voice like
that's some deeper work but if you
figure that out it'll allow you to stop
listening to it
step two is
to start to eliminate the things in your
life now that make that voice louder
maybe you're hanging around some people
who you shouldn't be friends with
anymore you know maybe just because
you're friends with somebody in high
school doesn't mean you should still be
their friend now you know maybe you've
Grown Apart
and now it's time to get some new
friends
okay do an audit of the people that
you're following on Instagram and on
YouTube and any social media I mean
whatever you're feeding your brain with
don't audit and think about are these
people
which voice are they empowering
there's a great story about two wolves
you know I'm going to paraphrase it but
there's two wolves inside you one who
wants the best for you and one who wants
to grow and learn and improve and serve
and share and be courageous and the
other wolf is is scared and Afraid and
keeping you small and stuck and insecure
and weak
and it goes well who which wolf wins
who's the wolf that ends up carrying the
day
and the answer is the one that you feed
so if you feed the wolf all your
insecurities and fears and doubts then
that that wolf is going to win and you
will be afraid and full of insecurities
and doubts and if you feed the wolf that
makes you feel bold and courageous and
Powerful then you will become that too
so that process we need to recondition
ourselves by changing the environment by
being around the people who are doing
the things that we want to do
so do that audit of the people you
follow on YouTube and Instagram and how
much of your time here's here's the test
is when you walk away from a video when
you walk away from the app that you're
on you feel better about yourself
feel Bolder more courageous more
powerful if you're watching this video
you know when you watch my channel do
you feel better about yourself or you
feel with more belief ready to take on
the day yes great hey I got more videos
for you stay tuned no I sincerely
apologize
because that is not the goal but but
then if that is happening then then yes
unsubscribe for me and go follow some
other people
you know and same thing for all the
people you follow on Instagram how many
of those people
make you feel better do you leave your
phone feeling better about yourself more
courageous balls ready to start today or
do you just waste a whole bunch of time
and feel worse about yourself great
those people unfollow them everybody who
makes you feel that way stop following
them and replace them because I
guarantee you that if you look for the
light you'll find the light
oh it's a good one you know if you look
for the light you'll find the light
there are people
on every social platform in every part
of the world who are spreading kindness
spreading belief spreading hope
spreading possibility they exist
everywhere
it's not common
it's not the default yet that's why lack
of belief I believe is the world's
number one problem because it's not
default yet but there are people
spreading to like
find them be around them hang out with
them collect them learn to collect good
people
it'll shift everything
so you've got a real important decision
to make
do you listen to your heart
the the feeling that you want to do more
and serve more and help more and be more
and create more or do you listen to that
voice
that's not your voice
inside your head telling you all the
reasons why
you can't do it
the choice
you have to decide which wolf you're
going to feed both walls exist inside
you the insecure wolf
and the powerful wolf
and either one could win
they'll dramatically change your life
which one you feed
you just have to decide which one are
you going to feed today rule number nine
is live intentionally the difference
between a great day and a mediocre one
is your intention
how did you decide to show up today most
people have no intention most people you
wake up you check your phone you're
falling into other people's emergencies
other people's demands and your time
what everybody else wants for you to do
today right everybody's got an agenda
everybody's got opinion on what you
should do with your life you open your
phone there's all sorts of other
people's emergencies for what you should
be doing right their emergencies become
your priorities because you don't have
intention in the day where when you flip
it when you start to say no I am going
to take control of my day take control
of my life and start to live with
intention everything starts to shift
the most important part of my morning
routine is intention
every day here's what I do I wake up I
am tired I am I'm groggy I'm I'm like
forget what day it is forget what year
it is significant who I am I wake up I
got stuff in my eyes I got lines on my
face so you know I'm just I'm groggy I
don't wake up excited and like yeah oh
my god let's go we're filming content
today you know I have to remind myself
of what I'm doing and
as I walk to the bathroom
I'll usually put on a song and in the
morning usually I have some oldies
playing because it just makes me happy
so I'll put on some oldie and I'm going
to the bathroom and I find myself just
starting to dance a little bit which is
great because the motion starts to
change things if you put on songs that
make you happy that make you moving it's
gonna start to shift your entire day
and music is the fastest way to change
your state and then as I'm going to the
bathroom might be too much detail I'll
then look at my calendar
I'll look at my calendar
and I'll say how do I want to show up
what's my intention for today
what is my intention for today for how I
want to show up for whatever's in my
calendar today
and today is a Tuesday Tuesdays are when
I make videos I don't know when this is
going to be released but
what's my intention this morning I look
at my calendar I see I've got a bunch of
YouTube videos that I'm going to make
today I'm going to go with Nina and
she's going to run some errands and I'm
going to film from the car
and I want to make content that matters
I want to make something that matters
today I want to I want to make something
that's going to inspire somebody today I
want to make a video that touches
somebody's life today I want to make
potentially the best video I've ever
made today
I want to speak some truth into the
camera I want to touch somebody's soul
in the content that I'm making that's my
goal for today
you think that changes how you show up
right it's like as opposed to just oh
I'm gonna make some videos today okay
cool cool let's go do that
that process doesn't have to take an
hour in the morning
right that process is while I'm going to
the bathroom right it takes takes a
minute
not very long
but it shifts everything
because it it changes
how you show up for the entire day
I've also got on my on the background of
my cell phone the background says
remember your intention
as a trigger so anytime I load my phone
I can see that between videos and I
press stop and I'm loading the next one
I see the background of my phone again
remember your intention like yeah what
was my intention this morning because
even if you set it up in the morning
doesn't mean the whole day is going to
be amazing something's going to throw
you off
you come back to your intention what was
my intention today
and it works for being
your business goals it works for
accomplishing your business goals it
works for your personal goals on
Saturdays is my fun day and they'll
usually plan something to do with my
wife Nina and maybe it's a hiking trip
maybe it's a we're going to go out and
try out a new restaurant like it's fun
it's not it's not chores it's not tasks
it's not business it's just something
for us to do so the intentions showing
up is different what's my intention
today well my attention is to be the
best husband I can be what does that
mean like not just words but you're
trying to feel it what does that mean I
want to have a great day with Nina I
want to make her smile today I want to
make her laugh today I want to be
present today I want to not be
frustrated by some little thing that
happens I don't want to be sucked into
anything on the work side I don't want
to be daydreaming about business I want
to be thinking about
my life with Nina I want to be
daydreaming about where we're going to
go together as a couple right and the
words will change
but even now that just saying that puts
me into a different mindset I got to
bring it back I want to make killer
videos for you guys
we just don't have intention
you know we know we want more you know
you want more you know you want more to
life you know you want to accomplish
more you know you want to be more you
know you want to serve more
and that's a great feeling but we don't
hold on to it long enough to actually do
something with
and we'll usually think of that I want
to do more I know I'm capable of more
and use it to beat ourselves up to say
well look I did I didn't do it I should
have done it last week I should have
started last year I was too afraid to do
it we just beat ourselves up and blame
ourselves for not doing more as opposed
to using that intentionality to then
create a better life for ourselves today
and it starts with today it starts with
today like right now the rest of today
can be different if you chose to with
intention show up
so how do we do it how do we how do how
do we do it today how do we do it
ongoing because if you woke up with
intention for the next year
hold a cat is your life look different
step number one
is create the environment of
intentionality and why that matters is
because it allows it to happen on on
Auto on repeat automatically without you
having to think about it because as soon
as you move it to conscious does that
does that step does that barrier does
that block where when it's unconscious
and automatic you're much more likely to
do it so
uh the environment right so my office if
you see my office I got the pictures on
the wall they all mean something to me I
walked past in the morning I walk past
my mannequin uh of of I have a mannequin
in my office or on the way to the office
of of me wearing the hoodie because
superheroes have mannequins of people
wearing their outfits and it it it fires
me up it gets me going I have the music
right put music for how you want to feel
not for how you currently are feeling if
I put music for how I currently was
feeling in the morning and I'm just
tired and just waking up it'd probably
be some slow meditative calm birds
chirping
um waterfall kind of stuff which which
there's nothing wrong with that but it's
not how I if I ask myself how do I want
to start my day it's not with birds
chirping and waterfalls it's with
something that gets me moving because
what I'm missing the most is fun I'm not
feeling fun and energetic in the morning
and so I need that but when I put on the
lion sleeps tonight or when I put on
runarounds or I put on uh
respect you know Aretha Franklin when I
put on you know any of these oldies
I just start moving I start dancing
start singing at the top of my lungs and
that gets me going in the morning right
so the more you can have these habits
and these triggers in the morning to get
you set up
so that when you're looking at the
intention of the day
you're already in the right frame of
mind okay because if you don't have the
right mindset going in no matter what
your intention becomes it's really hard
to get it actually firing right because
you can tell yourself I want to have a
great day but if all you're thinking
about is how slow everything is and how
crappy your life is how you're not
further ahead and how tired you are you
could say the words but it won't land as
strongly so the the environment really
matters step two is you have to look at
your calendar and see what's ahead and
come into it with intention how do you
want to show up for all the things that
are in your life today
what's on your calendar and schedule
things in right like create a calendar
that maps to your ambition your calendar
should be a macro reflection
of your intention your calendar is an
intentional life
what's in your calendar should be a
reflection of what you want out of your
life
so look at your calendar this is a great
weekly exercise to do look at your
calendar
and then see what in your life what in
what in those spots actually will let
you live the life that you want so you
say you want to be a YouTuber you say
you want to be an entrepreneur say you
want to be a great husband or wife you
say you want great show me in your
calendar where you have dedicated time
to make that intention happen because if
it's just a hope and it's never
scheduled in guess what it never happens
I'm filming content today on a Tuesday
because it's in my calendar because
that's part of an intentional life for
me where if I waited to get inspired to
do something I would make not a lot of
content
right
most of your goals are not in your
calendar and so they never get done
there's a tweetable most your goals are
not in your calendar so it never gets
done
so intentional life is putting things in
your calendar
an intentional day is in reminding
yourself in the morning of what you want
to do is how you show up so when I'm
showing up to make videos I already
explained the process that I go through
but then at night when I'm going to have
time with Nina it's different right the
the I'm not thinking about YouTube
videos anymore I'm thinking about my
time with Nina so an intentional life in
your calendar and in the morning an
intentional day just look at your
calendar and say here's what I need to
do today here's how I need to show up
because again if you plan your week on a
Sunday and planned it all out looks
great
you're going to wake up on a Wednesday
and then forget why you set that as your
goal
not show up with the same intentionality
anymore so the morning reset for
intentionality matters and then step
three is triggers so Step One is having
the environment and the routine step two
is planning out intentionality in your
life which is your calendar and on a
daily basis when you wake up and then
step three is the triggers to bring you
back when you need to so my biggest
Triggers on my cell phone my biggest
trigger is
remember your intention
so that anytime I check my phone I see
that as a reminder to myself of the
person that I said I was going to be
today
the other thing that really helped make
a big shift in my day-to-day life is I
schedule things in 25 minute increments
so I'm doing interviews I'm doing calls
I'm doing
whatever's in my calendar is in 25 or 55
minute increments before I go to the
next thing I have a five minute buffer
before going into the next thing so if
I'm doing interviews Thursday is my
interview day boom boom boom boom boom
boom boom boom boom 25 minutes back to
back to back to back to back to back the
occasional 55 minutes before the next
thing and I would do it initially just
as a buffer for timing
so in case something went over in case I
had to figure out some tech gear or kids
had to go to wash him or whatever I had
a five minute break in between as a
buffer
but
the happy accident that came as a result
of it is I use it as a little
intentionality break for the next thing
so yesterday when I'm mentoring my team
if I'm talking to
Jeremy for 55 minutes and then I have
Alex coming up next that five minute
break in the morning it's going to be
how do I want to show up for my team
it's mentoring day I want to show up I
want to be present I want to guide them
I want to help them grow and learn and
be inspired I want to be the best leader
I can be I want them to come away from
today inspired motivated ready for
action fill them with courage and belief
right that's the morning
that sets the tone for the whole day
but in the break between Jeremy and Alex
that five minutes
I'll use a minute or two of it to set
the intention for the next one I just
came from Jeremy I'm going to Alex how
do I want to show up for Alex and I may
just be repeating the same thing that I
came up with this morning or there might
be some Nuance that would be something
different there might be something
unique about Alex that I want to remind
myself of before going into that call
with him
so the daily
reminders of the intention the daily
triggers
one is a cell phone background remember
your intention
and two is having the break the five
minute break between switching tasks to
set myself up for the next task I
remember why I'm doing that specific one
the intention matters
you know again we wake up and
it's so easy to fall into somebody
else's plan for us it's so easy to look
at our text or look at our emails or
look at social media and feel like we're
already behind and we already owe so
many other people in our lives our time
and we don't control our day
and you have to put up
some walls
around where you're spending your time
and you have to start your day with
intentionality to say this is the life
that I want
and I'm doing the activities that move
me towards my goals
and the more that I'm intentional the
more that I am present
the more I will actually start to
accomplish those things
you have so much greatness in you you
have so much heart and so much care and
so much soul and so much of a desire to
do good and serve and help and yet for
some reason at the end of the week it
just didn't happen this week again and
it didn't happen again this week again
the difference is creating an
intentional life for yourself and then
reminding yourself daily and throughout
the day
of what that intention is
you don't need any more money or any
more support or anything else beyond
what you already have you have
everything you need to win
the only difference between now and
where you could be in a year
is how much are you going to show up
with intentionality every day to move
closer to your goals and Rule Number 10
the last one before some very special
bonus Clips is slow down sometimes you
need to slow down the speed up sometimes
you need to take a pause you need to
take it easy you need to take a step
back from what you have been doing to
say well what do I want and does this
still serve me is this still the life
that I want to be building am I still
building something that I'm I'm happy
with
or not and this is where a lot of
entrepreneurs struggle because we are
very goal oriented right raise your hand
if your goal orientated is that you
you've got goals you want to go off and
accomplish them we're Achievers and
Achievers get their self-worth and sell
value from hitting their goals and
checking the things off their Alyssa see
I did that I accomplished that
when people ask me what my 10-year goal
for myself is that I don't know
how are you supposed to know what what
you're going to look like in 10 years
think about who you were 10 years ago do
this as a quick exercise think of who
you were 10 years ago who were you 10
years ago
what were your goals what were your
aspirations what your Ambitions what
were your dreams
could you with any certainty with any
degree of certainty predict that you're
going to be here 10 years later
if the U from 10 years ago is making a
10-year plan for yourself is this where
you would end up
probably not no right not if you're
growing not if you're learning not if
you're improving not if you're watching
channels like this and you're investing
into yourself
the idea that you would be here is crazy
because a lot of the stuff didn't exist
and because you've you've grown and
learned yourself and so there's nothing
wrong with having plans I think they're
great I think having goals speak to your
Ambitions but you have to be willing to
jump off course when it no longer serves
you
the danger of having a 10-year goal for
yourself is you're thinking small
anybody who has 10-year goals to
themselves are thinking small because
you have no idea what you're capable of
in a 10-year window and you have no idea
how the world's going to change in the
next 10 years so if you could hit your
10-year goal but it's tiny compared to
what you could have done
if you're a little more flexible right
so you have to be willing to jump off
your 10-year plan
to go do something else because you're
being called to it
and that's where slowing down really
helps
to get great ideas in a shower
I get great ideas in the shower do you
get great ideas on vacation I get great
ideas of vacation they get great ideas
walking through nature one of my
favorite things to do walking through
nature when I walk through
forests just a quiet walk with the dogs
I get ideas I get great ideas I get
great ideas on drives I've started great
businesses off of different drives
I started a business with Bo who's an
entrepreneur I invested into now it's a
mid six figure business
because I was going on a hike through
the forest and then I was driving home
and it was about an hour and a half
drive and I was reflective and for some
reason this is how it comes this is why
slowing down really matters for some
reason I'm thinking about bow in the car
I may not have thought about Beau for
a couple months why am I thinking about
bow all of a sudden all of a sudden it
just comes
I want to start a business with Bo
we're going to start an agency together
where we book guests on people's shows
and now we've done that he books some of
the biggest guests in the world from my
channel he booked Mel Robbins he booked
Matthew McConaughey he booked Deepak
Chopra he's booking all sorts of crazy
guests through my channel and he does it
as a service for other people
to book great guests for their shows too
and he's passionate about helping people
launch their shows and get great
conversations and build their brands and
spread an amazing message out to the
world and so we started this business
and and he quit his job
now has a mid six figure business doing
this
because I went for a walk and had a
drive and then called him or sent him a
message
and that's how a lot of the great things
have happened to me in my life a lot of
the great ideas the the next Ventures
the the Innovations and the
breakthroughs come
from slowing down
the over-scheduled entrepreneur doesn't
come up with great ideas
the over scheduled entrepreneur might be
really efficient if you jam-packed your
calendar you might be really really
really really efficient
but you really reduce your effectiveness
and so life will go through these Ebbs
and flows these ups and downs and you'll
have these moments where all you need to
do is get work done there's been there's
been many times where I don't need any
new ideas right now I just need to
execute on what I've got in front of me
many times and so being efficient really
really matters
but when you then move to a place of we
see some friends we move some place of
creativity
where it becomes about coming up with
the next invention the next new thing
the next place that you want to go right
then then you have to be
having chunks in your time in your
calendar that you can allow yourself
that freedom
so if I look at my day my calendar where
I spend my time I like having one day
per week to be project day so Wednesdays
for me or project day where I have the
whole day to work on whatever projects I
want to work on and then Friday I call
CEO day where I get to work on the big
picture things to grow my business
and one of my favorite things to do on
Fridays when when it's not too super
freezing outside here in Canada is go
for a walk to start the day go for a
walk clear my head I've got the whole
day ahead of me to be the CEO of my
business and and ask the question what
does that look like what does being the
CEO look like what's the next version of
Evan Carmichael
and I often come up with fantastic ideas
not all the time you know sometimes you
just go for a walk and it was great to
clear your head and get some fresh air
and that's all that came from it and
sometimes you get fantastic ideas
because you took the time to slow down
and have that in your calendar
so a couple things
how do we start the how do we start to
execute and put this as part of our
regular routine because what most people
do is you wait for your life to break
before you make a change
you wait for life to get so bad that
something happens most people don't go
on a diet and fix their health until
they have a heart attack right like you
don't actually make a change until
something breaks and forces you to
change but you don't have to hit rock
bottom you don't have to be in that
negative a situation you can be a little
more proactive and slowing down allows
you to do it so a couple a couple steps
one
puts time in your calendar every week to
have a little bit of reflection it
doesn't have to be a whole day like I do
on Fridays but a walk
put a 20 minute walk a half an hour walk
it's good it's good anyway they get a
little bit of cardio it's good anyway to
get outside and get some fresh air
but but book in a half an hour walk once
a week at least somewhere in your
calendar where you're not just on your
phone and you're not just stressing
about what has to get done but you have
time to actually
just be by yourself
and watch
suddenly as Solutions come to you right
so one
put that 30 minute walk somewhere in
your calendar once a week
two
pay attention to where you you don't
love the things in your life anymore
quite often there's things that we
started with and we're energizing and
enthusiastic about and we love doing and
it was filling us up with energy and
then slowly became a job
you know I think as such as
entrepreneurs we love starting things we
love we love the beginning of something
right is that you hands up is that you
you love starting something from scratch
you love building but then we don't love
maintaining we don't love keeping it we
don't love the ongoing work with it
right there's a lot of entrepreneurs and
so that's me too
and so at that point when you stop
loving as much of the day-to-day grind
on it you still love the idea of it you
still love doing a high level work
around it but you don't love doing all
of the itty bitty stuff you either have
to let that thing go
or you hire somebody to help you with it
right it's either gotten to the point
for me it's either gotten to the point
where I can now hire somebody because
it's it's gotten to the point where it's
monetizable and I'm making some money
from it maybe not huge money but enough
to bring somebody on to help with it or
I didn't it failed it's not making money
and I don't like it anymore and so you
have to drop it
and this is again where our 10-year
goals let us down because we might be
super excited by it's like okay in 10
years I'm going to build this thing up
but the actual path needs to be actually
six months in you got to jump off that
and go do something else because you
don't love it anymore and you didn't
build that big enough
so Step One is do our 30 minute once a
week walk get some get some fresh air
and some time for yourself and then step
two is think about what are some of the
things the areas in your life that
you're not happy with anymore that maybe
used to bring you value but not anymore
you don't love the process of it and how
do you start to offload it because part
of
coming up with new ideas and creativity
is unloading the things that are filling
up space in our head in our calendar and
chances are there's lots of stuff that
fills up space in here and space in your
actual calendar that don't actually
serve you anymore and maybe never did
and it's time to let them go
either just drop them
slowly pass them on to somebody else
or hire somebody to help you with it
as you build and as you grow you're
going to have to let go of things
there's a great um example A friend of
mine who started his business he has a
hard time saying no to people you know
is that that you I have a hard time
saying no to people too he's a hard time
saying no to people and as his business
built and grew and became more
successful
the demands on his time became more and
more
pressing and he had to choose okay where
is my time going to be spent and some of
the people that he used to spend time
with or some of the organizations that
he used to donate some of his time with
he couldn't do everything so now it's
time to reprioritize
and so inside of that he said well what
where do I want to be sending my time in
with whom
and he had to let some of those
organizations go
it's sad it's hard but he had to let
some people go and let some of the
organizations go because it wasn't
either the most effective use of his
time
or to the most fulfilling like there's
nothing wrong with doing volunteer work
or helping people but it's got to feel
it's got to feel fulfilling to you
and we're constantly playing that game
like where you spend your time
with whom on what projects
is the game for the rest of your life
you're just leveling up the size the
impact the amount of care the amount of
good that you can create
and so again the over-scheduled
entrepreneur is not very creative
is not coming up with life-changing
life-breaking decisions
so step one is to schedule in that time
to get out there do your walks
allow some freedom
for new things to come to you
and then step two is doing that out of
your life of where
things no longer serve you of where your
10-year plan is falling apart and needs
to be fixed so you don't wait for life
to completely break on you before you
decide to make a proactive change
forward
self-confidence comes from doing
difficult things self-confidence
self-love self-respect it all comes from
deciding to do something difficult
here's what happens when when something
hard comes up and you find a reason why
you can't do it
it's too hard it's too difficult it's
too scary
most people let you off the hook people
around you will say yeah yeah that's way
too hard I mean the fact you even
thought about it was crazy
you let yourself off the hook
but then you realize
could have done it you know like that's
the worst feeling in the world that you
could have done something
but then you came up with an excuse as
to why you can't
and that will eat you up
and even if the world lets you off the
hook
recognize that they have lower standards
than you
recognize that the people who are giving
you that advice and padding on the back
and saying it's okay you don't need to
do it
they don't like their life either
they're stuck they're trapped
they're not pushing hard they're not
being aggressive for their goals they're
not tough either
and we're reinforcing that Comfort Loop
every day comfort you versus growth you
are in a fight there's a war going on
inside you comfort you versus growth you
comfort Evan versus growth Evan every
day there's a fight there's a battle
there's a war going on and you need to
decide who's gonna win the fight
it's a daily thing and the more growth
you wins against comfort you the more
you start to grow the more you start to
hit your goals the more you start to
have an impact the more you start to
love yourself
because again even if the world would
let you off the hook
you know it's just an excuse
I think most people think of it as a
giant step that you have to take to
build that self-confidence it's not I
think it's much more about the daily
battles with yourself that then builds
up to Major things just like you don't
go to the gym and lift 400 pounds you
start by lifting five pounds or ten
pounds or 20 pounds or 40 pounds
whatever it is that's how you start to
build the muscle it's much more about
the Daily building of the muscle to show
yourself who you are much more than the
one-off heroic moments here's an example
so uh yesterday we had an insane
snowstorm here in Toronto I don't know
if we can that's kind of blurry you
can't see we had like you see some here
behind me it's like you can see that
mountain of snow behind me we had an
insane snowstorm we had probably the
worst snowstorm in Toronto Canada in the
decade I have not seen this much snow in
a crazy amount of time and so I'm going
for a walk
uh rocking and rucking is where you
carry a backpack so I'm carrying a
backpack of 20 pounds
as I'm walking doing my normal walk and
it's it's crazy outside normally the
rucking alone is hard enough and I just
increased the weight in the backpack now
there's no path to walk on and this
morning I was walking through an area
and there was Zero path the snow is up
to my knees and I need to get through
so what's what are my options well I
could I could complain and turn around
right like oh I could look out the
window and say ah so much snow I'm not
gonna do that I'll do it when there's
less snow you know and then the next day
there's less snow there's still snow in
the next it's still snow and then all of
a sudden you just gave up on the Habit
right like you let yourself off the hook
to say I'll do it tomorrow and then and
then you never do it and then the
habit's gone and that's what you're
teaching yourself this is why it leads
to Identity this is why it leads to
negative self-worth and negative
self-confidence because the next time
you come up with an idea you've already
reinforced the training you're training
yourself that when you come up with an
idea you don't do the thing when you say
you're gonna do it and you're gonna
start tomorrow and then you don't the
next time you come up with an idea guess
what you you've already reinforced the
product I don't follow through I'm not
going to do that I'm excited today but
tomorrow I won't follow through
so this is snow it's up to my knees
right up to my knees and I'm six one so
it's it's some serious snow like I gotta
walk through not quite that that's
that's probably taller than me I don't
have to walk through that much but but
up to my knees
I'm looking at it and I've got to go I
don't know
100 meters through this thing
and initially my thought was
oh man why is there no path why is
nobody shoveled this why has nobody
still Blowfish like gotta get over there
I got a backpack on I'm rocking I'm
sweating like crazy I'm already
exhausted now I gotta go through this
this is when we need to catch ourselves
right everybody would have let me off
the hook
and another me would have let me off the
hook right Comfort admin would have let
growth happen off the hook so it's okay
go back home
or go the long way around where there's
a path don't go through that snow to
your knees
and as soon as I caught it
now what
most of the time you won't catch it most
of the time you'll just do
you'll do the automatic thing and
usually the automatic thing is is the
comfort thing so usually play small by
default usually you you look outside and
see the snow and not go just by default
not even catching the the conversation
with yourself
but when you catch it
this is a really important moment what
do you do do you do the difficult thing
or do the comfort thing
because when you catch it and you make a
conscious choice this is how we start to
either change our Identity or reinforce
our identity
so I looked at it I caught it and said
I'm going through let's go you know I
caught the negative thinking I caught
the Comfort Evan coming over walk around
go home nope not happening we're going
through we are going through we're gonna
make it through
and it was rough
you know I'm walking through I'm
freezing uh I'm taking one kind of giant
step at a time snow is getting all
through my boots all down my legs I I
almost slip and fall I have a coffee
that I that I picked up uh it's dripping
all over the place
and in my head as I'm going through it
it's like this is the best
let's go let's go Evan you got this man
let's go you do difficult things that's
the thing on repeat in my head
combined with that
I'm also telling myself that you know
what not only am I doing this difficult
thing for me I'm also creating a path
for other people that the next person
who comes up against this 100 meters or
so that now they will have not an easy
time but an easier time of crossing the
same path
so they can get across
so it's going to serve us
if you're ever having a hard time
getting yourself to do something
it's one you do difficult things remind
yourself and two default the service
that it's not just about you it's for
other people now that may not even be
true
maybe nobody ever comes across that path
maybe I didn't make it easier for the
next person maybe somebody comes five
minutes after me and snow blows the
whole thing and so there was Zero
service
it doesn't matter it's the story that
I'm telling myself that it will serve
other people that will get you to then
do the difficult thing
so in order to make it happen
there's two triggers that I use one is
language so scary difficult or hard if
you say those things if you feel those
things if you text those things if you
write those things if you're talking to
yourself and you catch those things then
you have to do it you can no longer
accept scary difficult or hard as
reasons for you not to do the thing
because your great life is on the other
side of scary difficult heart everything
you want the business you want the
relationships you want the help that you
want everything everything your great
life if you wrote down a list of
everything you want out of life
everything on that list comes on the
other side of you doing scary difficult
and hard things
growth you that's growth you fighting
comfort you
so when you catch yourself sane speaking
writing thinking scary difficult to
heart that's a that's a trigger it
should be a trigger it's a trigger for
me it should be a trigger for you to go
and do it do it go walk through the
giant snow and you might be thinking
well how does that help me with my
business it's just walking through snow
and I'm going to be cold and have snow
in my boots how does that help me
it's an identity thing
because as soon as you start to teach
yourself that you're the kind of person
who follows through on those scary
difficult hard things
then the next time that shows up
anywhere in your life in your business
and your relationships in your health
anything that actually helps you
accomplish your goals you're going to be
ready to show up for it you're going to
be more likely to actually do the thing
because you've been training and
conditioning yourself to do the thing
that's why walking through 100 meters of
snow matters
so the first is scary difficult hard
those are verbal cues or thought cues
the second is the boom boom boom test
where your heart is beating quickly it's
like when your heart is going crazy like
that
it's usually because you should be doing
something you're afraid right now don't
again go don't go don't go standing on
the highway because it's scary and it
makes your heart race right don't be
stupid but most of the things that
you're afraid of
aren't actually things that are going to
be life-threatening
right they're not they're usually it's
other people's opinions usually you're
afraid of not failing but somebody
watching you fail right you're gonna
fail at something who's gonna see you
that's what we're actually afraid of and
that cannot be a good enough reason it
can't not anymore if you're afraid of
losing in front of somebody if you're
afraid of other people's opinions if you
are living your life based off of the
expectations and Judgment of other
people you will never do anything great
you will never live your great life
because somebody always has a plan for
what you should be doing with your life
you will never please everybody it's not
possible
you have to start to learn to please
yourself and it's not doing something
just to show off and just to prove
somebody wrong I'm not a big fan of
tapping into that energy the reason to
do something is not to prove somebody
wrong and make somebody else look stupid
the reason to do something is because
that's who you are and that's what you
want to do
and so learning to do difficult things
teaching yourself step by step RIP by
Brick one snow storm at a time
teaching yourself that
will change your life
you deserve a better life
you deserve a great life
and that comes on the other side of you
doing the things that are scary
difficult and hard you are the product
of the five people that you spend the
most time with you've heard that before
you know it's important and the reason
why it's so true is because of a concept
in Persuasion in that whoever is more
confident wins
whoever is more confident in their
opinion on something in their habits on
something is the one who wins and
persuades and influences other people to
join them even without having to say
anything just somebody being so
confident in their own negativity in
their own world and their own bad habits
without even telling you anything you
will naturally pick up on that thing and
dive down that same negative rabbit hole
with them and and that that's the fight
because if you are around people who are
negative who have the bad habits that
you don't want to have anymore it's not
that it's impossible but you're making
it a lot more challenging on yourself to
be able to pull yourself out of the hole
you are the result of the five people
that you spend the most time with so
let's say you want to work out you want
to work out you want to be healthy this
is the year you want to lose weight you
want to be in the best shape of your
life amazing right
but it's a new habit and this is the
problem at the very beginning of a new
habit if we go back to the concept of
persuasion
you don't have a lot of persuasion over
yourself yet you don't have a lot of
influence over yourself yet on this
habit because it's so new
so it's easy to get pulled in a million
different directions you're looking for
any possible reason why not to do it and
if you have a goal to go to the gym
every day or you have a goal to eat
healthy today
and then you see your friends around you
just diving in on Big Macs and lying on
the couch and complaining and being
negative
you can fight that
but at some point that fight starts to
wear down on you and your resolve isn't
strong enough yet because it's too new a
habit and so it's likely to happen is
you're gonna go join them because they
are more confident in their negative
approach than you are in the positive
approach they have such a history with
the bad habit
that didn't influence you to go back
down that negative path I remember
hanging out with a very popular YouTuber
and uh he was asking well how do I grow
even to the next step and I'm I love how
consistent you are he's talking about my
channel how consistent I was and when I
was
with him over dinner
one of the things that I struggled with
is when I travel I usually let my diet
go you know I'm traveling having fun I
don't have my usual routine and so not
that I would just smash Doritos down my
face but I would just eat whatever and
he was at a restaurant with me and he
was eating really clean he had a fish
and salad and no dressing and just
really really clean and was waking up
the next day he was gonna go for a run
some of those habits are what I do here
when I'm at home but I don't do it when
I travel and so here he was admiring how
consistent I was on making videos and
having however many thousands of videos
now on the channel and I was admiring
how consistent he was in his eating
healthy and his working out now what
would happen if we started to hang out
more
if we started to hang out more and we
look at those two things the consistency
on making videos and the staying healthy
on the consistency of making videos I am
so
it's just part of me now I'm so
confident in my making videos and that I
have to get it done that even if he was
lying on the couch all day not that he
would but even if he was he wouldn't
negatively influence me so I would suck
him to making more videos he would be
making more videos as a result of
hanging out with me it would just
naturally happen without me even saying
anything to him because here's what
would happen he might be on the couch he
might be getting distracted might be
doing something else I said okay man I
gotta go make videos and by me going off
and making videos it will motivate him
to go make more videos I don't have to
say anything your actions speak way
louder than your words don't tell
somebody to go do something you want to
influence and persuade them go do the
thing and they'll see you doing it now
it's in their environment and it's gonna
suck them in so if we hung up together
he would be more consistent on the
content
on the other hand if we hung out
together consistently
I would get healthier with my my travel
diet if I traveled every time with him
then we would likely eat at more healthy
restaurants he would likely be working
out every morning I would likely join
him on some of those he would just
hold me towards being a healthier
traveler compared to what I am now
because he is so confident in that habit
that he's trying to build and so where
we struggle as entrepreneurs is we're
trying to build these new habits we're
trying to pull ourselves up to a better
brighter future better place more proud
of ourselves but we're still stuck with
the people around us who are in a
negative environment who want to stay
stuck who just complain about where they
are instead of actually trying to build
something better for themselves so if
that remains your friend's Circle in the
next five years it's going to be really
really challenging for you to get to the
place where you want to be okay well
that's that's great Evan how do I change
it I mean I don't want to just leave my
friends I don't even know where to get
new friends how do I start this process
there are three big strategies I want to
give you that I think will really really
really help first off you don't have to
go off and tell all your friends hey you
guys suck I'm better than you I don't
want to hang out with you anymore
right so step one is just do an audit
just do an audit of your friends just do
an audit of the five people that you
spend the most time with just think
about it in the past two months who have
you spent the most time with and then
how many of them make you feel better
about yourself where you leave them
feeling more bold more confident more
excited for your life more ready to go
and take on the big challenges that are
ahead of you and hand me them make you
feel worse how many of them you have to
go home and have a nap or how many of
them you just feel drained as a result
of talking to them not that they're bad
people they're just in a lot of pain
right again I don't think like there are
toxic people I just think that they're
in a lot of pain and and hurt people
hurt people right so if you're not
strong enough yet to influence them
they're gonna suck you down so step one
is to do an audit of your friends step
two is to limit access to the people who
are making you feel worse about yourself
again it doesn't mean you have to go and
tell them that they suck just just stop
spending time together
as you spend less time together you find
that the relationship just kind of
Fizzles away you don't have to have some
big conversation just kind of access
spend less time go out once a month
instead of once a week call them less
frequently stop doing things together
you'll just notice that as you spend
less time together
you stop getting influenced so
negatively people are so afraid of
breaking off a friendship because you
think you have to have this really tough
conversation you don't
you don't you just have to spend less
time with them just look at your
calendar see how often you usually spend
and your goal for next month is to spend
half the amount of time or a quarter of
the amount of time that you spent with
them as last month that's it that's step
two it doesn't have to be some big break
doesn't have to be crazy scary it
doesn't have to be overwhelming and
massively painful
three is it going to be to fill the void
so if you stop spending time with people
two things happen one you get this void
it's like well who do I spend time with
now I have this extra time in my
calendar I've got these blocks and the
other thing is you start to feel lonely
you know if you don't have that friend
circle around you anymore it's easy to
feel lonely which is maybe even worse
than spending time with them at least
you have some kind of connection we're
settling for just okay relationships
because we crave the connection because
you just want to have somebody around
you because it's better to be with that
person than it is to be alone
and that's the biggest fear is that
you're just gonna end up alone that
you'll never find anybody even in
romantic relationships but also in your
friendships because it can be harder as
you get older to join friend circles to
make new friends is why a lot of people
are still stuck with the same friends
they had in high school and University
because they never actually went to go
out and search for new friends because
it's so afraid that you're gonna be
stuck alone so in that vacuum in that
void in that hole in your calendar now
what are you gonna do well the goal is
to now meet new people and you don't
have to treat it like it's dating it's a
relationship you just go off to the
events and the and the people that you
feel like you might have a connection to
so I'm introverted I'm shy I am not a
people person I hate networking events I
hate small talk
and so how I would do it if you're
extroverted it's super easy just go and
go to the events and hang out and say hi
and say hi I'm Evan good to meet you I
would never I never go up to anybody and
say hi I'm Evans it's great to meet you
what do you do I just I never do that
um so the easy way to do it is think
about the clubs the activities and the
events that are really interesting for
you that it's a lot more natural for you
to have a conversation about so if there
was just a business networking meeting I
would hate that I hate that kind of
stuff where you have to explain what it
is that you do and they don't really
care or interested in but finding common
Hobbies
so for me
I would pick entrepreneurship I would
pick League of Legends I would pick
salsa dancing and signing into Minecraft
so maybe maybe some Minecraft I would
pick something in those four areas where
I could easily connect with people that
it doesn't feel like a chore to talk
about because I love that topic as a
quick example
um I was on an airplane and I was flying
to Brighton burchard's event in Puerto
Rico and so I was I was one of two
external speakers coming in to speak at
the event and this is his high level
Mastermind these are people who are
paying 30 to 50 000 to be in that room
and I'm flying down there and you know
I'm in business class there's only one
person next to me and he's trying to
strike up a conversation and I I just I
just don't like it it's like so where
are you going like what we're going to
Puerto Rico like where are you coming
from I'm from Toronto and he was coming
up from Vancouver and I just I hate the
small talk right I hate the small talk
and so I think he kind of noticed after
a couple tries that I wasn't really
interested in talking to him I didn't
mean to be rude I just it doesn't
fulfill me I'd rather just be by myself
and alone and focus on what I need to
talk about and so we're flying down
there
and I don't really know why he's going
or what you know what he's going for
what his business is in Puerto Rico if
he's speaking if he's got an event what
so we don't really talk for the rest of
the way not anything rude just we're in
our own world
I get there and get in my uh my taxi or
Uber whatever and drive to the hotel
where we're staying
and as I'm checking in guess who shows
up right behind me
right next to me on the counter the same
guy that I spent all this time now just
sitting next to not talking to on the
airplane
and he said hey you're here too it's
like and as soon as I knew that he was
here for Brendan burchard's event it's
like yeah man are you here too oh my God
what's your business
as soon as I found out that he was an
entrepreneur it's it's way easier to
have a connection and so we spent a
little more time there chatting spent a
couple a couple of moments over the over
the course of the conference as well but
it's so much easier to make connections
when you have a joint interest right if
I know you're an entrepreneur or I know
you care about League of Legends or
Minecraft or salsa dancing if I know any
of those things we are instantly going
to be friends and have something to talk
about
but if you're just a normal human who
maybe I don't know anything about then
it's a lot more difficult so
because you have this vacuum and you
don't know who to connect with and you
want to feel that connection and
belonging with the group
don't let that hole and that pain drag
you back to the circle that you know
doesn't ultimately support you and look
for the events that are exciting for you
to go to for the clubs for the
activities that you are generally like
oh that'd be so cool to be able to go
there and you'll end up meeting
like-minded people and that becomes your
new friend Circle and when that happens
when you hold on to good people like
that you actually stop even caring that
some of the people
you know I've kind of drifted or you've
let go of at some point instead of
spending once a month with them now
maybe it's once a year just catching up
or maybe you don't talk again not again
because you've had some conversation and
they hate you you've just Grown Apart
and the last time you spend with
somebody the more you're gonna grow
apart you are the product of the five
people that you hang out with the most
you've heard it before you'll hear it
again when is the time to actually take
the action do the audit of your friend's
Circle do they make you feel better
about yourself or Worse about yourself
stop spend as much time with the people
that make you feel worse about yourself
and then feel the void fill the vacuum
with people who lift you up by going to
events and clubs and activities that you
genuinely care about it's not just a
strategy to make connections but you
love being there you will meet some
amazing like-minded people figuring out
your core values I think is one of the
most important exercises that you can do
as a human being
like how do you know how to live your
life how do you wake up every day and do
what you want to do how do you have any
Clarity on what to do next when you
don't know what you stand for when you
don't know your most important core
value it's the reason why I wrote your
one word
I don't know how many years ago the
concept is you have one most important
core value what is it figure it out when
you understand what it is it'll shine a
giant Spotlight on your life to realize
oh this is why I'm not happy like if you
are ever not happy
frustrated stressed out
it's because there's too many things
that are going on in your life that are
out of
congruence with your single most
important core value
so if you look at mine it's belief right
I believe is my single most important
Okay cool so I'm happy when I'm doing
things that make me feel believe and
it's something that you you have for
yourself but it's also something that
then you give to other people so you're
on a mission the idea becomes I want to
spread building for myself and I also
want to help other people believe in
themselves more whatever you come up
with is a core value is for you is what
you still need the most right now I
still need belief right now
but it's also something that we want to
give to other people whether it's the
world if you're watching this video is
probably world big mission but it could
just be the closest people to you you
know if you're saying the most important
core value is family then you want to
bring more family to your family
every single most important core value
is belonging then you want to give
belonging to everybody to yourself you
still need to feel more belong yourself
and you want to give that to the world
or your closest friends and family
but that's that's the game you have to
figure out your single most important
core value
if you feel like you're being pulled in
a thousand directions that's why you
don't know what you stand for if you
feel uneasy about something or unsure
about the decision that's also why you
don't know what you're saying for and
when you figure that out it gives you
the courage to take the action required
when you understand what your single
most important core value is it allows
you
to step into your career yourself to
step into your bold self it gives you
the permission to move forward where old
you wouldn't have done it you know if
you had those moments where you really
want to do something
you're inspired you've got a great idea
it's like you want to serve you want to
help you think this could be amazing and
then you stop yourself you know you stop
yourself oh I who am I I can't do that
I'm not I'm not well known enough I
don't have the money I didn't go to
school for this I don't have the
connections with the parents right we
stop ourselves
we we we're planning to plan and getting
ready to get ready but we never actually
do the thing well figuring out your core
value allows you to have the courage and
strength to step into who you want to be
how can my one word be believed if I'm
not willing to do the things to believe
in myself even something like this
feeling on the street this used to
terrify me I remember the first video
that I made when I was walking down the
street
uh it's probably about a decade ago my
agent challenged me to do it and I was
terrified I was terrified the people
might judge me I was terrified that uh
just looking foolish and looking bad I
don't know it was just terrified filming
in public and I remember I was filming
and I made sure I walked down just this
really quiet street where nobody would
see me and made sure I looked around and
nobody was there and I started filming
and then there was a male woman who came
by she was delivering mail I didn't see
her before I started filming and so
as she walked by I I thought I was like
this
put the camera down you know it's like
I'm not doing anything nope and then
when she left you're like okay back to
filming and uh
you know now now I mean how many
thousands of videos later I'm much more
able to get out in front of the camera
and create but what's the thing that
helps me push what's the help what's the
thing that gives me the confidence or
courage to do that thing that was
incredibly scary at the time well
believe hey my one word is belief my
most important core value is believe so
I need to I need to step into it
it's a it's a constant reminder
it always forces you to be not the
version that somebody else wants for you
but the version that you want for you
believe was was is inside me it's not
that it was just given to me by somebody
you don't have to have Believers your
core value either you can figure what
yours is
but if ever you're stuck with a big
decision
and you're not sure what to do and you
actually know what your most important
core value is then guess what happens
forces you to go and take some action
because otherwise you're operating
against yourself and you don't need
somebody yelling at you or telling you
what you should do you know what you
should do
because you have the awareness around
your core value when I wrote your one
word it was it was designed for
entrepreneurs
because it's about how to find your core
value but then how to build into a
business and
I was surprised that a lot of the people
who like the book were not just the
entrepreneurs but the the spouses and
the family members of the entrepreneurs
who read the book to say okay they don't
want to start a business but they need
this first part kids in school are
reading the book and send me pictures
and tweets as they go through the
curriculum to figure out what their most
important core value is like can you
imagine being in grade six
seven eight ten
and knowing what your most important
core value is and using that as a lens
to which you can make decisions for the
rest of your life
how beautiful is that
I wish I had that I mean that's why
that's why we do what we do right that's
why that's why authors write books
that's why entrepreneurs start
businesses is we want to solve the
problems that we had for ourselves when
we want to make the path a little bit
easier for other people right that's why
we do what we do
so how do you find your core value well
you can you can pick up your one word
you can pick up built to serve but as a
starting point
think about who your favorite teacher
was growing up and why
think about your favorite teacher of all
time mine was mine was Madame Farr who
was my teacher Mentor in my last year of
high school but who was yours who's your
favorite teacher growing up and why and
specifically on the why wasn't because
they taught you a certain subject I
didn't like Madame Farr because she
taught me French right I don't even use
French day to day at all even living in
Canada we don't use French
but uh but shock me to believe in myself
so there's one what's your favorite
movie of all time and why mine is
Seabiscuit I love sea biscuits about
this horse it's way too small to win not
supposed to win a jockey that's way too
big to win and not supposed to win an
owner that has no money and is not
supposed to win it's like all the stuff
that's not supposed to happen and yet
they all find each other and somehow A
Miracle of Miracles they figure it out
and they win a whole bunch of races it's
based off a true story it's it's a
belief story at least for me when I
think about that movie why do I love it
well it's about belief
think about your parents
you know maybe you love your parents
maybe you hate your parents uh what do
you what was the biggest lesson that you
learned from them like what did you love
the most even if you didn't like your
parents or didn't think they were there
for you or you know whatever what what
did you love about them or if there's
nothing redeemable that you can find
then what did you wish that they gave
you what do you want to give to your
kids right current kids or future kids
if you had to give them one lesson what
would that be again mine is believe my
parents always taught me hey you're
having because really Carmichael you can
do anything you believe that you can so
believe is a Common Thread through all
these things if you think about oh this
why is this why does this matter if you
think about all the things that made you
come alive all the things all the best
moments in your life all the positivity
all the happiness all the the best
moments in your life
there's a Common Thread between them you
know so for me as bully Matt I'm far
Seabiscuit my parents the Common Thread
is believe
when you figure what that threat is for
you what it allows you to do is now
design a life going forward with more
intention
so now instead of it happening by
accident you know I just happen to find
that I'm far I just happened to find Sea
Biscuit it wasn't intentional most of us
are not doing that with any level of
intentionality it's just that
random things happen and every now and
then one of those random things are good
right but now it allows you to design a
life with more intentionality to say
this is what I stand for
this is who I am at the core
these are the things that make me happy
I want to chase down the feeling of X
believe for me right I want to chase
down that feeling I believe more I want
to be around the people who help make me
believe I want to create content in the
business that inspires people to believe
I want to hire teammates
people on my in my business we got 40
people now I wanna I wanna bring on
people who believe in the mission
believe in spreading believe believe in
each other right it's like it just gives
so much more clarity
and intentionality for the rest of your
life
and so I think it's one of the most
important exercises that you can ever do
just as a human I don't know why we
don't teach this stuff in school you
should
because how do you operate your life
without knowing what you're saying for
how do you operate without knowing who
you are
that seems crazy
and it's not that difficult and you
don't have to go meditate on the
mountain for five years to figure it out
you don't have to hire a ten thousand
dollar coach to figure it out just ask
yourself those questions
who's your favorite teacher growing up
and why
what's your favorite movie of all time
and why what did you love about your
parents or what's the gift that you want
to give your kids the most important
core value coming through those things
that'll give you a much better path and
direction
and Clarity and strength and courage
for the rest of your life focus on one
idea and make it work focus on one
business model focus on one Revenue
stream focus on one social media Network
and make it work so many times we're
focused on too many things we're
distracted and our entrepreneur ADHD
kicks in and as a result nothing happens
for all the people who are telling you
to have 13 different passive income
streams because if one goes away you
still have all these other 12 mostly
people who start off doing that make
zero money from all of the passive
income streams you're making ten dollars
a month four dollars a month seven
dollars a month where instead if you
could focus on one thing
and maximize it and make it amazing and
put your energy into it you will see
exponential results I look at social
media as an example and I just finished
this training where we did the seven day
built to serve challenge it was amazing
had so many awesome new thought leaders
coming to the program people got a big
message want to serve and one of the
questions I kept getting asking is
how do I be on every social media
platform how do I be everywhere how do I
get started and just blow up everywhere
and it's like you don't right the answer
is don't don't don't try to do that
if you are the person right now who is
trying to be everywhere look at your
social media accounts
chances are you're sucking everywhere
chances are not not you suck as a human
just the results aren't there the
effort's not there the energy is not
there because you're so forcing yourself
to just get out there and create content
and be in all the platforms
that you also have a million other
things that you have to do and so as a
result you're you're creating
really mediocre content
content that people aren't interacting
with and if people don't like what
you're putting up it's not going to lead
to results for your business and so much
much much much much better it doesn't
mean that you can't be there you know it
doesn't mean that at some point you
can't be there that as you build your
brand and you get bigger and you hire a
team and you have more money that you
can start to do this but much better at
the beginning is to figure out
what is the one platform what is the one
Revenue stream what is the one business
model the one thing that if I focus on
that thing
it's going to lead to results so then I
can scale
entrepreneurs have a hard time with this
because we want to do so many things we
have our add brain going on and
we don't want to just do one thing we
also feel like it
is limiting for what we want to do right
if you have a big Vision a big mission a
giant goal for what you want to
accomplish if doing just this one little
piece of it feels too small
the way that I would structure it and
think about it is this is just a
sequence
you still get to do everything
you still get to do it all
you just have to go in order you have to
create a sequence that the thing that
you need to focus on at the beginning of
your business whether it's your Revenue
stream whether it's a social media
success whatever it is what you have to
figure out is how do I start to as soon
as possible get a sustainable business
for myself so that I can quit my job if
you have one so that I can bring income
in for myself my family so I can start
to afford to hire a team even if it's
part-time or one person so you can scale
up your company so that I can then go
off and do all the other things because
some of your ideas are are amazing and
huge and require more people and time
and effort and energy and some of the
ideas can get started a lot faster and
so if you want to go and accomplish your
big goal your big dream your big mission
then it's important to think about the
sequence of things that instead of doing
everything all at once and as a result
all of the results being mediocre focus
on the one thing that if you push that
lever you really maximize that thing
you could start to make more money you
could start to have more impact you can
start to have more reach you can start
to see more success that then allows you
to bring on more people to help you
build and scale
for me we've got 37 people on the team
now
and
I can do so much more you know because
we got team than if it was just me by
myself doing everything and so in
building my mission I want to solve the
world's biggest problem right people
don't believe in themselves enough and
so in building that up I need people I
need help I need support I need team I
need I need a lot more than what I've
got right now
but and be able to build a business that
can bring in money then I can afford the
higher team that helps me accomplish a
lot more things and take on a lot more
projects but if I was at the very
beginning of what I was doing right now
I would not be doing most of the things
that I'm doing right now
I'd still be accomplishing and going
after the same mission
but I'd have to pick one thing to focus
on
I think the one thing at the beginning
that I think I could make some money
doing this so that I can live I can I
can pay you know rent mortgage
I can pay my internet bills I can pay
for some food not not living you know
fancy life but just being able to live
and survive so I don't have to have a
job and then I would start thinking okay
how do I then scale this one thing that
I'm working on
to build up to the point where I can
remove myself or at least take some of
the pieces off so that I can hire a team
to help build and scale and grow if I
look back at my YouTube Journey here I
did everything at the beginning you know
I I uh I filmed it I researched it I
edited it I did all of it and it took a
crazy amount of time and I made a lot of
mistakes and I did a lot of stuff that I
probably shouldn't have done and
just by focusing on that thing and
making content and creating videos it
then allowed me to make a little bit of
money but then I could hire my first
part-time editor that then turned into a
full-time editor that turned into a
second editor and a research person that
turned into someone helping with the
thumbnails and the graphics and it
continues to build up and scale but
everything I was doing myself in a
mediocre way but getting it done
to then be able to scale out a team and
so most people are just stuck doing too
many things you start like look at what
you're doing on a day-to-day basis look
at your calendar you have a limited
amount of time right you have a limited
amount of time there's only so much you
can do in in a day in a week you have
other responsibilities maybe you have a
job maybe you have family kids health
that you have to look after you know
there's a certain amount of time that
you have that you can dedicate to this
thing that time needs to go into the
right efforts
and again it's great to have that big
mission and big goal and big dream but
if you have a limited amount of time
every day or every week
and you are
trying to create 13 passive income
streams with that limited amount of time
no one of the streams ever gets enough
energy enough effort Enough of Your Mind
space enough of your creativity Enough
of Your Love to ever become anything
and so you're diversifying way too
quickly you're diversifying way too soon
and apply that for anything that you're
working on apply that to your your
business and the and the opportunities
that you're chasing the Partnerships
that you're looking at the things that
you're saying yes to the social media
networks that you're trying to be on
do yourself a favor
don't try to be everywhere not yet
right just understand there's a sequence
to things and you can make it so much
easier for yourself to have more impact
to make more money to have a bigger
influence to be more proud of yourself
to start getting more success and more
results and more momentum so much easier
if you just sequence it out
so that you don't have to do everything
all at once you don't have to feel the
the handcuffs and the Restriction of
saying well I don't want to do this one
thing for the rest of my life this is
where it gets
you know entrepreneur Ade kicks in right
and we don't want to be locked in I
don't want to do the same thing forever
well you don't you won't do it forever
that's not the point the point is not to
do this one thing forever that if you
took these 10 opportunities in front of
you
you could do all 10. you could do all
10.
just not all 10 at the same time because
if you do all 10 at the same time none
of them are going to work out
and often it's a small opportunity that
can pay you more quickly
that can start to build the momentum for
you so if you have your list of your 10
opportunities in front of you 10 things
that you could do great look at what
order should I go in
so I can start making money and start
building momentum one last quick example
I look at a lot of thought leaders a lot
of people have a message a lot of people
want to be speakers and authors and
coaches and influencers and
they've got big goals and big Ambitions
for what they want to create
when I'm helping someone like that
usually the first option is coaching
the best thing to do at the beginning is
coaching so we're going to dive into one
specific business model right if you can
look at let's say be a speaker
getting brand deals as an influencer
writing a book and coaching
if we had those are four opportunities
in front of you right let's say so what
did I say being a speaker getting paid
to speak getting paid to do brand deals
getting paid to be an author and selling
books even selling courses your own
materials and training and Etc and
coaching
those are those are you know four or
five different business models that you
can go through perfect
at the beginning which one is the best
what should you focus on
coaching
why
people don't like the idea of coaching
because you're trading your time for
money right I don't want to trade my
time for money okay
well what are you doing right now you
know you're at a job because if you're
at a job you're trading your time for
money
if you have unlimited time to figure
stuff out and you have you have a giant
bank account then you can do something
different but if you need to start to
make money to build this thing up then
yes you're trading your time for money
but it's a faster path to get you out of
your job and into your business
full-time
where everything else takes a lot more
time
speaking takes an incredible amount of
time if you want to if you want to be a
paid speaker and and get paid enough
that it's actually meaningful
it takes a lot of time for you to get
good at the skill as well as for you to
build up momentum and the name in the
industry you have to do a lot of free
speaking gigs before you ever get paid
to do it so if you have a horizon of
years awesome but I'd rather you start
getting paid immediately while we work
on the speaking career you want to be an
author and get paid to have a book cool
you can go and sell publish a book right
now if you wanted to you can get it out
you'll make you know you can sell it to
your friends and family your your
audience you'll make a a few bucks but
it's not going to be anything meaningful
to get a paid deal or to have a
significant even if you're going
self-publishing to make a lot of money
off your book you have to have a big
audience
to get the deal with a publisher they
want you to have at least a hundred
thousand followers that's like your
starting point to get in so is that
achievable of course but now we're
looking at years as a horizon as opposed
to like this has to happen right away so
you're not getting paid right now off of
your book so if you're sitting there
thinking right in the book creating a
great manuscript creating a great how-to
guide it's not going to be the thing
that helps get you any kind of money
anytime soon and I want you to get paid
because most people quit too soon on
their ideas or they're trying to do a
million different things at once right
if you're trying to create a course
same thing you have to build up enough
momentum you spend so much time making a
course creating the content filming
videos or writing instruction manuals or
creating the PDFs or whatever your
course structure is it takes so long to
make the course
and then you have to go and Market the
course and people don't know who you are
yet you don't have a brand yet so could
it work absolutely will it pay you more
than coaching yes absolutely most likely
it's way more easy to leverage that than
coaching
but again the timeline is so long
and most people quit too soon on it
where if you were coaching you can you
can make money right away as long as you
have something that can actually help
people right if you're good at what you
do you know how to solve somebody's
problem you can make money as a coach
right away and yes you're trading your
time for money but it's better than
having a job and it also gets you closer
to your customers at the very beginning
I'm much I'm a much bigger fan of
selling a service than a product because
it gets you closer to your customers you
get to know their problems you know
their issues you know what exactly
they're struggling with and you can help
them solve it which allows you to create
a better book a better course a better
product because you've worked with
enough people through the problem
and so most entrepreneurs fall into the
category I want to do all of it great I
want to be a speaker I want to be an
author I want to create my course I want
to create my book I want to be a coach I
want to do all of it awesome you have a
limited amount of time every week
to work on all five of those things at
the same time means there's very little
progress how if that's you and you've
been writing your book how long you've
been writing your book for
like when is it going to come out what
year
how many speaking gigs have you done in
the past three months
all right how much time has gone into
your course it's like we start and stop
and start and stop because we're
tackling so many different things
because you want to do it all and you
want to have income streams coming in
like crazy and there's nothing wrong
with that it's amazing but there's a
sequence
there's an order
that if you can as soon as possible
inside of your purpose
start to make money start to build
momentum start to be able to bring on
team to help you it's so much easier you
can go so much further you can go so
much faster you can have so much less
stress
you can have such a big impact
that you just need to focus
you just need to focus it's all possible
your big dreams are possible
go in order figure out the sequence that
will start to get you paid
Focus the number one rule for success is
you have to love what you do you have to
love the process of the thing that you
are doing I've studied more successful
people than most people in the work that
I've done on my YouTube channel my
website before that that's been 20 years
when did I start doing this it was 20
22 when I started teaching
how you can model success for your own
success right that was through my
website and I'm I'm 41 and a half now so
almost 20 years of doing this 20 years
of studying the most successful people
and trying to dissect their lessons and
bring them out for you to enjoy
and the number one rule that I found
over and over and over and over and over
again the people who achieve at the
highest levels whether you're an
entrepreneur you're an inventor you're
an athlete you are a musician you are an
artist the number one rule
is that you love the thing the actual
thing not just the results of what you
get not just accomplishing the gold
medal or getting the thing that's on
your dream board getting that house or
getting that car not that the actual
work so that it doesn't feel like work
you know that old expression of uh find
something you love and you never work a
day in your life and it's really true I
look at my calendar and I see what I've
got to do uh every day I've got to make
videos it doesn't feel like work you
know I don't look at this like how lucky
am I to be able to make videos in the
car and that's my work day right
a lot of people would step into my life
and hate this great you know I would
step into a lot of people's lives and
hate that too
that's the challenge when you're
stepping into somebody else's life or
your or you're helping somebody else
build their dream and you don't actually
like the process of what you're doing
you're not going to be happy first of
all and you're not going to be
successful either you're always going to
know that you're capable of more doing
something bigger something better and as
long as you you're stuck with your foot
on the brake
you're gonna know you're capable of more
on just being too afraid to go chase
down the potential so the number one
rule for success is you have to love
what you're doing I was doing a
presentation yesterday Brendan
burchard's influencer Summit and it's
part of the biggest event every year for
people who want to become influencers
thought leaders experts get their
message out to the world you know my
kind of people you got a message you
want to share with the world let's go
and I'm trying to solve the world's
biggest problem and and I can't reach
everybody but you can like you can reach
people that I can't reach with your
message and so I love you and we'll try
to help spread the techniques and
strategies the motivation as well the
belief that you have a powerful voice
and getting that out there to the world
so yesterday I'm I'm doing my one hour
talk with Brendan
and
I shared my graphic of my growth over
the years and it's it was really slow
growth at the beginning
very little results
uh you know 60 subscribers or whatever
to 100 subscribers you know I'm on year
five and I'm still still in the four
figures of subscribers and it took a
long time for me to get out of my own
way took a long time for me to get
comfortable in front of the camera it
took a long time for me to feel like my
story meant anything had any kind of
value like why do you want to learn from
me when I'm you could learn from Oprah
or
Elon Musk or Bill Gates or whoever the
person is took a long time
and we've done now
I don't know how many thousands of
videos we're over 10 000 videos that
we've made
and so somebody asked me well like how
do you keep going how did you keep going
when you had no results at the beginning
when you weren't becoming famous or you
weren't getting a lot of feedback or
recognition and how did you make so many
videos
so consistently right if you average
that out that's that's over a thousand
videos a year
how did we make over a thousand videos a
year sounds crazy just thinking about
that that's three videos a day every day
for 12 years
it's pretty crazy how do you how do you
maintain that level of consistency and
not burn out where some people are
burning out
after six months of being on YouTube
well I love what I did
right I always focused on who I was
serving instead of who I wasn't because
the who you're not serving game
never ends you know if my main channel
has three million subscribers why does
it have four or five or seven or ten or
40 right that game is never ending
but if you focus on who you are serving
who you are helping who is paying
attention who is valuing from the
product Services content you're creating
it makes you feel better
because focus on who you're not serving
puts you in a position of
Act Right of like you're not good enough
people don't care and it starts to take
a knock on your self-worth but when you
focus on who you're actually helping and
serving and that somebody got value from
your your message today your product
your service today it gives you extra
motivation to keep going like how do you
persevere it's because you feel like
you're doing something that matters
if you woke up and felt like today
didn't matter you're not likely to stay
very consistent right it's like if
nobody's nobody's gonna watch nobody's
gonna care nobody's gonna buy my thing
well what reason you have to get up and
go work on that thing you're probably
gonna quit but when you feel like it
matters even if it's to one person
then what you're gonna make today will
matter will mean something to even just
one person if you actually felt that
you're gonna show up completely
differently than if you felt like it
didn't matter
so I always focus on who I was serving
instead of who I wasn't
and then the second part to that was I
actually enjoy the process of doing it
you know so when I see filming day on my
calendar or when I see interview day on
my calendar
it's not work it's not like okay I gotta
go to work and then I'm gonna have fun
afterwards when I get asked that on uh
on podcast how many hours do you work
or how do you how do you stay so
consistent on the content
I respond with well I'm here talking to
you on your show
is this work for you because it's not
worked for me this is fun for me
it might be considered work I guess to
it's my business it's part of business
time but it doesn't feel like work
the days fly by because I'm enjoying
the actual work of what's going on I
enjoy the process and I think that's the
key and when you find the people who who
have had tremendous success you'll find
that they actually
enjoy the things they're doing and that
the days fly by
and it's a good sign when it's not you
know like if your day is not flying by
if you're stuck and you're struggling
doing something
chances are that's the wrong thing for
you
that's the thing that you need to give
up on as soon as possible and maybe that
means you need to quit on the whole
business like if the whole business is
giving you nothing but stress and
problems and you don't want to go in and
you don't want to work on it anymore
maybe you pick the wrong business maybe
you you did what most people do is they
pick an opportunity just because they
think it's a hot business because it's a
trending industry to be in for this year
but if you don't actually ever like the
thing you're gonna quit on it and you
should quit on it so you can go find
something that you actually love right
so if you pick the business just for the
opportunity
because you think you're gonna make a
quick buck
you're gonna hate your life get out of
it ASAP or it might mean there's just
little bits inside the business that you
don't want to do
and maybe you have to do it
and you have to do it for now until you
can afford to hire someone to do it or
maybe it just doesn't have to get done
you know maybe maybe that's not required
you know there's some things that have
to get done that you might not enjoy
right filing taxes
most people don't enjoy filing taxes
most entrepreneurs that I've met do not
enjoy filing taxes as as a part of their
business but if you don't want to be uh
in trouble with the government then you
have to file your taxes you know it's
important part of being an entrepreneur
and so maybe the beginning you do it
yourself but as quickly as you can you
want to hand that off to somebody else
to do let them do it because they love
it and they're great at it and it allows
you more time but also just mental
energy because
it's not just about the hours worked
when you are working on something that
you do not enjoy doing at all that two
hours feels like 20 hours
can you relate you know like doing two
hours of work that you hate feels like
it took an entire week to do of mental
energy versus when you're actually
having fun doing it and it doesn't feel
like work you could keep going and
you're you're producing so much and time
just seems to fly by
so use that negative time as a filter
so when you feel that way that you're
not happy you look at your calendar and
you're not happy about what's coming up
that's a that's a great time
for the awareness to shift something
needs to shift
if you look at your calendar you can do
this homework right now look at your
calendar see what's coming up in the
next two weeks
is it exciting for you are you pumped to
go do it or are you dreading it or
apathetic towards if you're like you
could take it or you could leave it
and if there's nothing that's exciting
in your calendar nothing that scares you
in your calendar in a good way like it's
growth opportunity then you need to add
something in and if you're constantly
dreading or hating the stuff that is in
your calendar you need to get out of
that because you will never win doing
work that you hate
people say that you know do whatever it
takes you won't not consistently not for
a sustained period of time you could do
anything in a short amount of time but
over over years decades you won't you
won't stay consistent on doing something
that you hate you'll never win because
you're going up against people who love
it
whatever Market you're in
if you don't love it
and it's just a strategy for you
and somebody else your competition loves
it they they live it they eat it they
breathe it they bleed it they love it
that's them and for you just a strategy
and you hate it who do you think's gonna
win in the long term
it's not gonna be you
but meanwhile there is something you
could dive into that you could love
the actual work not just the results but
the actual work
and you have to find it
I've studied so many successful people
over the almost 20 years now 19 and a
half years of doing this
and the reason why I went to
non-entrepreneurs as well
was because it's all the same lessons
that success in athletics and success in
music and success in art and success in
every field
still comes down to
you need to love the process
love the work
and if that's you and you love what
you're doing you have to keep going and
find a way to make it work or you'll
regret giving up on it
and if you're the opposite and you hate
what you're doing you think it's good
strategy
the best strategy is to get out and go
find something that you love because
that's where you will win everything in
your life changes when you learn to tie
your self-worth to your effort instead
of the results most people tie their
software to the results to winning you
only feel good about yourself when you
win if that's how you think then you're
screwed because that person only takes
on projects that you know you have a
pretty high chance of winning at and
therefore you play small for Life the
key is to tie yourself Worth to the
effort to trying and if you do that well
you'll win Beyond Your Wildest
imaginations so let's use me as an
example look at this video right here
this video
two minutes before getting on to making
I'm nervous I'm scared
I don't want to do it I'm trying to find
a reason why I don't have to do this
video
now why I've done 6 000 of these videos
do I not love it anymore nope that's not
it I love doing it so why am I afraid
who cares I've done six thousand
the answer is because I don't want to
make it the same way that I've done the
past six thousand
I want to push harder I want to push and
do something new if I was just doing
what I've already done then it'd be easy
right if you're doing the same thing
over and over and over again it becomes
easy but then
you get bored
you start to hate your life
you start realizing that everything is
just a photocopy over and over and over
and over and over again
and so how do I push through
I put this pressure on myself to say
this video right now has to be the best
video that I've ever made that's my
intention going in to every time I'm
filming most days I don't accomplish it
when you're trying something new and
scary and bigger and Bolder most the
time you won't get it you fail a lot
but I tie myself worth my respect to the
effort I'm trying and every now and then
you'll make a bit of a breakthrough you
get a bit of a win
and the nose accumulate and then you get
another one and another win and another
win and so the answer isn't have a big
goal and then find a reason why you
can't do it the answer isn't dream big
and then convince yourself of some
logical excuse for why you're not going
to take action the answer is to push
through
the answer is you're scared and you're
gonna do it anyway the answer for me is
I'm gonna make another video I'm gonna
try and push myself harder and I think
that's what Achievers do because
Achievers are failing more than you
because most days I get up and fail most
days I'm just feeling it's another
failure another failure another failure
but the more you fail the more you're
eventually gonna win
I'm gonna get massive results
because you tie yourself Worth to your
abilities to get up and try again and
try again and try again and pat yourself
on the back for the effort you're
putting in not just when you're winning
so how do you do it I'm going to give
you a three-step process that I think
will help step number one is what I call
the pillow test this is my actual pillow
that when I'm in Toronto I sleep on
every single night and the pillow test
is make yourself proud before you hit
your head on the pillow right before you
go to sleep tonight before your head
hits your pillow you ask yourself am I
proud of my effort today not how much
did I win not did I get the results I
was looking for not that I get my
million views or close that big sale are
you proud of your effort are you proud
of your effort can you put your head on
your pillow tonight and say man I am
proud of the effort that I put in
that's the test that's the test for
tonight that's your test for tomorrow
night and the night after that and the
night after that and the night after
that and the more that you get a yes to
say yeah
heck yeah
heck yeah I'm proud of my effort you do
that you watch your business explode
step number two is expect to suck at the
start anytime you're trying something
new expect to suck don't expect to just
try something new and it's amazing this
is where a lot of people fall down
you've had some success you're at a
certain level you're going to try
something new before you go up you're
probably going to go down
that's part of the experientation
process it doesn't mean you suck as a
human it just means that you don't have
the skill sets the talents yet you're
trying something new
I haven't brought props in on my videos
before that was a new test I expect it
to suck maybe on an off chance that
works amazing I learned from it but when
you're trying something it's brand new
you don't have the confidence in it yet
you're still figuring out the path
expect to suck when you put so much of
your worth into expecting to be great
the first time out here's what happens
you try one thing you record one video
you watch it back say man that sucked
and then you never make your video again
meanwhile if you just kept doing it you
would eventually be awesome you'd
eventually crush it go back and watch my
first videos come back go back to my
main Channel go back to the beginning
see where I started I've kept them all
up so you can see the journey the
progress of how much I sucked at the
very beginning it took me 350 videos
until I wasn't embarrassed by my content
I was I was so embarrassed I couldn't
watch it back
350 videos but I kept going
the problem is people are quitting on
things too soon you quit on something
too soon because you're not getting
immediate results expect to suck it
doesn't mean that you suck as a human it
just means you don't have the skills yet
I had to get the skills by practicing
and number three is ask yourself what
would the most bold version of you do I
got this question was talking to my
video guy Danny who came to me with a
really important personal problem in his
life at the time and he said what would
the most bold version of you do just
came out man I love that
and anytime he doesn't know what to do
he asks himself that question what was
the most bold version of me do it's a
great question because it allows you to
push through a lot of your fears a lot
of your insecurities
to force yourself to be bold and you
want to be bold
you're meant to be bold
you're meant to create amazing wonderful
things you want that big vision of yours
to come true you are bold you are
courageous
but we don't live in that land very
often and so if you ask that question
what would the most bold version of you
do today
what it does is wash away a lot of those
fears and insecurities and gives you the
answer that you're actually looking for
I'm super introverted and shy and this
it took me that's why it took me so long
to get going on YouTube because I I
don't uh I don't like the camera like I
don't come alive on the camera
um and the biggest fight I would get
into I've been agent in New York named
Steve who he helped uh Grant Cardone
blow up and now Robin's blow up and a
bunch of thought leaders and uh he's
like Evan you need to be famous like I
don't want to be famous dude and that
was our biggest fight for years yeah and
it wasn't until he either said it in a
certain way or maybe I just finally
wasn't you know being a dummy and like
could receive it uh where he said well
the more people know you the more people
will get the message yeah and for me
it's always message and impact driven
first more than my face being somewhere
um and so once I realized that like oh
okay so the more people know me the more
people will hear my message which sounds
basic you know but I you know for the
first five years I didn't understand
that yeah
um and so I'm I'm great at like two
things and apart from that I know
nothing about everything else
um and so luckily I guess in some of our
circles I have a knowledge on something
that people care about yeah
um when I when I went to that group you
know it's like well what am I gonna I
teach believe you know it's what I'm
what I'm in your book it's the whole
mission that I'm on and like I'm gonna
I'm gonna teach Anthony trucks to
believe in himself more or like Brendan
Bouchard to believe himself like why am
I here yeah yeah
like the YouTube side into to the point
of you know the Candor which you you
said graciously in the beginning
it's what Achievers appreciate yeah you
know I think for people at the very
beginning of their Journey most people
they need just the encouragement and the
the pat on the back and the high five
and like you can do this and get going
and create and just the fact that they
made a video or they they called that
person like it's a huge win the fact
that they took any kind of action and so
most of what I do is is just
cheerleading and encouragement because
that's what they're missing is just
momentum yeah for the Achievers though
it's like you don't you don't need you
don't need me to say hey trucks like
you posted a video great job man no it's
like okay that's cool but you're like
okay where does it suck how do I improve
it and you were asking some questions
too it's okay like be honest tell me
like rip it apart yeah shred it tell me
everywhere it sucks
um and so the Achievers want more of the
push because they're they don't need the
pat on the back like how do I get better
yeah you can change the negative
patterns that I run in your life
the patterns that you think are
impossible to break that have been with
you for life that will be with you for
the rest of your life you can break them
it starts with a decision and if you
don't want to still be in 20 years
living by that same negative pattern
that is holding you back
I think this video will help most of
what we do is subconscious most of what
we do is beneath the surface most of
what we do is
what we've been conditioned to do and
the patterns that we've seen and you
know if you're watching this you're
likely an adult and we've been running
the same pattern programming for a
number of years if not decades and
it can be really difficult to be able to
switch that pattern but I'm going to
give you a formula today that I think
will really help and one that I'm
applying myself as well in my life so
step one
is even just acknowledging that the
pattern exists and that you want to make
a change
what is the habit what is the negative
Loop that's in your mind what is the
thing that you don't want to still be
thinking in the next year two years five
years ten years what is that thing one
of the things that I'm working on is
moving to a space of great things happen
to me I had a great video coaching
session with Beth hendel and my big aha
moment that came from there was
I believe in the plan
so whenever I am thinking of something I
make a plan and then I execute the plan
and I do the plan and I follow the plan
and when I don't believe in the plan
then I create a new plan then I believe
in that plan and that's the thing that
gets me going so I'm very plain
scheduled calendar oriented that gives
me my security that gives me my identity
and so as long as I have a plan easy
peasy let's go waking up we're making
videos because it's in the plan
but then what happens on the rare days
you know maybe once a month where
I don't believe in the plan anymore I
don't think the plan is good enough to
get to where I want to go
and I can't make a new plan I don't know
what the next plan should be what I have
done so that I don't get lost and
spiraled down into negative thinking
into uh maybe not depression but
um anxiety and stress and overwhelm that
I don't know what to do next you ever
been faced with that like I don't know
what to do next
my plan has been my plenty I'm using the
words
just to tell myself
great things happen to me this is what
I've done it's in my coping mechanism
the the way out of the stress and the
anxiety and not knowing what to do next
is me telling myself great things happen
to me
and what Beth challenged me to do
and the big Insight that came from it
was living not in the identity of the
plan but living in the great things
happen to me so now I'm trying to shift
my identity from being the guy who
believes in the plan to being the guy
who believes that great things happen to
me that instead of using great things
happen to me just as a coping mechanism
on my worst days the once a month days
when I really don't believe that I'm I'm
getting closer to my goals or I'm never
going to hit them
and flipping that to being the default
mode that's that's really hard I've I've
was not born the plan guy it took me
decades I'm 42 coming up in May I'm 42
and it took me decades to become the
plan guy you know two decades to become
the planned guy
and now I'm I'm not
getting rid of the plan guy thank you
plan guy you got me here I appreciate
you you know Pat in the back I still
need you please stay with me on this
journey but I want to be the guy who
believes the great things are coming
because at the end of the day all your
great things all your great ideas all
your great breakthroughs usually don't
come as a result of the plan
it's a maybe a byproduct of the plan but
not a direct result of the plan because
the plan only is something that you know
exists right now it's it's what I've
talked about making decisions with your
head versus your heart big decision with
your heart song with the head the head
only understands the world that
currently exists where your heart can
create something brand new and so I want
to be I want to be in the brand new I
want to create something that hasn't
been done before and so the you can't
plan for something that hasn't been done
before and you need to have some faith
that great things will happen and so
that's a long way of me saying that I am
trying to become
the guy who believes that great things
happen to me as a default state
I believe that when I say that when I
create video and I say that on camera or
when I'm talking I believe that I
believe the great things come to me if I
keep going if I keep making if I keep
sharing if I leave with my heart if I
tap into what I feel is the right thing
to do even if it doesn't make sense I
believe that great things will happen
and I've seen enough of that happen over
my life and career that I believe it and
if you're not quite there yet
just look for some small wins that when
you have help when you have shared when
you have created from the heart you've
gotten some small wins and if you keep
going you can have
slightly bigger ones and medium-sized
wins and then large ones and then
gigantic wins if you just keep going so
how do I shift and we're working through
this in real time I'm not sharing a
story that is you know
it's 20 years old like I sometimes might
do the foundation story so how do I
shift how do I shift from being
the plan guy to the great things will
happen to mikai I think it could be
useful Mini case study for you if
there's something that you want to work
on
that you want to improve at you're tired
of telling yourself a different story
and you want to shift it so here's what
I'm doing first off is trigger words
right so if I say plan that's a trigger
word plan ooh plan here's my plan like
oof plan I said it again not that it's
bad right for years it might be bad it
might be it might be a critical you
telling yourself that you're stupid or
that you can't or it can't it could be
another a trigger word or hard it's
another trigger word the fact that
you're not going to do something because
it's hard that's a trigger word right so
what are the trigger words that you tell
yourself as to why you can't do
something or that keep you locked in
your negative patterns what are those
trigger words that anytime you catch it
you say it you feel it you tell somebody
else it that like oh there it is again
I'm noticing it you can tell the people
in your life your your family your
friends your spouse people on your team
you can tell them hey if I ever say this
word I want you to I want you to call me
out in it so you can have people kind of
support you through this journey as well
number two is you try to design in a
conscious way
applying it in your life consistently so
the next thing I did as soon as I got
off that coaching call with Beth was I
told Nina I told my wife and I said hey
great things happen to us I told her
what happened and great things happened
to us great things happened to us great
things happen to us and I honestly I
must say that at least 40 times a day
great things happen to me I'm talking to
myself or great things happen to us
if you want you can set it as a alarm in
your phone you could put it as a
background on your on your computer
screen you can put it as a sticky note
on the bathroom mirror or the door I
have a email that I sent myself that I
didn't delete out of my inbox so so I
always see it in my inbox every day when
I'm checking my email I check my email
once a day and it's always the last
email that I that I checked because I
never removed from my inbox and it says
this is your great things happen to
reminders
this is your great things happen you
reminder every time I say oh that's
right great things happen to me because
that's still not it's nowhere close to
being my default
but I'm working towards becoming that
person
so it's the decision to do it and then
with intention putting things into your
calendar so that it happens so again
maybe you're setting an alarm on your
phone maybe you're putting the picture
up on your wall you're telling your
friends and the people around you and
you're finding a way to repeat it to
repeat it to repeat it to repeat it and
I'm not judging myself as to I need to
get this done next week
I just want to make a little bit of
progress every day Beth's team reached
out and wanted to do a round two of
coaching and I said I'm still I mean
thank you it's amazing I'm still working
on the last thing you know the great
things happen to me
shift in mindset is something that I'm
working through and
it's incredibly powerful and I don't
think I need any help for anything else
yet I'm still working through this thing
this week has been a really challenging
week for anina and myself as well we are
we ran our build to serve challenge
which which was crazy
um when we first did it the the idea
that was pitched to me was seven days 45
minutes to an hour each day and we ended
up going the seven days and you know
three to four hours each day which I
didn't budget for but it was amazing
helping thought leaders and speakers and
coaches and entrepreneurs authors
just the energy and the vibe and the
love was so amazing that it took up an
incredible amount of time at the same
time we just bought a a brand new house
which is super exciting and so selling
this place and so I had to move my up
you might notice it's a different
background than usual I'm not I guess I
could have done it in my car
um but I'm not in my usual Studio my
office because we have a makeshift
office while we get our place ready to
list today
so we're packing and moving and
switching all the artwork and all of
that stuff while running a challenge uh
yesterday I hit the side of a a curb
that had a rock
not a rock like a boulder and it
punctured my tire and not just like
giant hole in my tire uh so okay we have
to go and get the car fixed on top of
everything else which is why I can't
film in the in the car like I normally
do because I don't have a car right now
because it's being fixed because we I
blew out the tire and just issue over
issue over issue and
my niece was with us yesterday
and she made a comment to my wife Nina
about how calm we were through
everything like okay well the car tire
got blown out uh that's that completely
changes how we spend the rest of today
now instead of doing these errands and
taking people here and all of this stuff
uh on Nina's birthday by the way
it's like okay well here's what we need
to do now you know okay we gotta get it
fixed we gotta figure out how to solve
these other problems and let's go and
she was my niece was blown away but how
we weren't arguing or fighting or
yelling or
uh super stressed just okay let's solve
the problem and keep moving around with
our day why because great things happen
to us
great things happen to us and that's you
know when something negative going on
even if it doesn't feel real
it'll be something that Nina and I will
laugh over great things happen to us oh
that happened okay great great thing you
know what great things happen to us
we will figure out a way through this
great things happen to us and in that
ongoing conditioning
the more that it's around us the more
that I say it I believe it a little bit
more and a little bit more and a little
bit more and a little bit more and I
guess you could call it affirmations I I
never really
connected to affirmations that much
because it felt
if I was saying something that I didn't
believe in that
that it wouldn't it wouldn't work for me
and because I already believed that it
wouldn't work for me then I've already
set myself up for feeling from the
beginning I think the key thing is if
you want to be able to change that
mindset you want to change the Habit
Loop you have to find something that you
actually on your best days believe
there's a kernel of Truth in there right
if you're 400 pounds and you say I'm
skinny I'm skinny I'm skinny I think I
think a lot of
in your head you say well that's BS I'm
not skinny and and then you don't
there's no even kernel of truth to it so
then you never do the actions to help
you get there
where on your best days what do you
believe about yourself on your best days
how do you handle problems
so when I say great things happen to me
I believe it
I actually believe that that wasn't
something that was given to me that
wasn't something that somebody once told
me that wasn't somebody that a coach
told me that okay you have to use this
now as your Mantra I believe it on my
best days I believe it I believe it I
can I can tap into that and I believe it
there's a kernel of truth to it and I
want to make that kernel you know grow
into something much much much much
bigger so homework would be to think
about
on your best days what do you believe
about yourself what what's the specific
language the specific words that you
would say to yourself to encourage
yourself or you're looking back and
you're proud of yourself on your best
days what do you believe about yourself
and then finding a way to make that a
daily part of your life
so that when the negative things come
you can tell yourself this as a reminder
and it starts to shift everything for
you you
hide whether you are going to live an
intentional or accidental life
do you want to live an intentional or
accidental life most of the world lives
in accidental life most of the world
they wake up what do you do when you
first wake up check your phone right you
set some alarm because you have to drive
to some job that you hate
you check your phone and immediately
there's all the crisis out there all the
expectations on you all of the fears and
judgments all of the tasks that other
people have set for you you wake up like
an accident and start living according
to other people's demands for your time
you've already lost complete control of
your day
what if though you swapped it and said I
want to live a more intentional life
what does it even look like was an
intentional life look like well I think
it starts with a value
if you were to think about what is your
most important core value what would you
come up with right I've written two
books on it your one word built to serve
back there you can figure it out mine is
believe I want to spread more believe in
the world
what is your most important core value
that you want to organize your day
around
instead of responding to other people's
emergencies and losing complete control
of your day how about we organize with
intention for how we want to show up
today okay well that sounds great so how
do you do it well I'm going to give you
a couple tips that I use in my life that
I think can be valuable for you
number one your morning routine is so
critical you've heard it over and over
and over and over again from multiple
people Morning Routine Morning Routine
Morning Routine what's the difference
between a incredibly powerful morning
routine that allows you to be
Supernatural and do the things that are
beyond your comfort zone and and are not
by default in you yet
versus just a regular morning routine
the difference is the feeling this is
what most Achievers Miss okay most of
the world doesn't have a morning routine
with intent most of the world wakes up
falls into their day respond to the
people's emergencies hate their life
hate their day look back on the week
that just happened if you ever felt like
you've put so much work into this week
right you look at the end of the week I
worked so hard this week but I got
nothing done you ever feel that way why
because you responded to other people's
emergencies instead of actually doing
the thing with intention that you should
be doing
okay so the purpose
for Achievers I have a morning routine
is to get the feeling the goal is not
just to wake up and do your workout or
do your meditation or do your prayer or
or whatever the thing is that's on your
list right we're great as Achievers at
checking off the boxes right check check
check check I did it awesome pat
yourself on the back you feel good for
checking out the box but if you do not
feel
old powerful confident courageous belief
in yourself to start your day and have a
great day then your morning routine is
not working for you more important than
the task you get done is how you feel
about yourself and ready to start the
day
some people what they need to do is
actually tweak them on a routine and
some people what they need to do is this
is more likely the case you actually
have a good morning routine you're just
not doing it with the right focus and
intention because you say that you're
going to watch a video to get inspired
great perfect but while you're watching
the video You're brushing your teeth and
you're making your lunch and you're
preparing your coffee and you're doing a
million other things so you can check
the box and say yep watch the video but
you didn't get the feeling
and so it doesn't count
you need to feel old courageous powerful
belief in self ready to start the day
and have an amazing one or you have to
go back and fix your own routine or do
it again starting your day to have
intention to do crazy new amazing big
things
it begins with a powerful morning
routine okay
number two
look at your calendar
and think about how do you want to show
up today the most important part of my
morning routine I'll wake up I put on
some music usually the first thing I
play in the morning is all these play
some really I don't know the oldies just
get me going in the morning any song
that kind of gets you moving gets you
flowing gets you out of your state
because we all wake up kind of tired
lines on your face Etc right but then
what song can you put on because it's
the fastest way to change your state
and then I look at my calendar
I look at my calendar and ask yourself
how do I want to show up for today
instead of having a a bucket list I
think your bucket list is your excuse
list things that one day you're gonna
get done forget that I'm getting stuff
done today you're getting stuff done
today your bucket list should be in your
calendar you're working towards actually
achieving things and so look at your
calendar for today look at your calendar
for the next week how do you want to
show up
so this morning I wake up and put on my
oldies and I'm looking at my calendar
and this is a Tuesday for today and I'm
filming YouTube videos on Tuesday
Tuesday is a day that I film my content
so how do I want to show up I want to
show up
present I want to show up and make some
of the best videos I've ever made I may
not achieve that objective but it's my
it's my goal it's my intention to show
up it's less important like did you get
the result today and more like are you
proud of the effort that you showed up
today I don't want to focus on team I
don't want to focus on emergencies in my
email I don't want to focus on social
media I don't want to delay and
procrastinate I want to get content out
for you guys believe Nation let's go I
want to show up even though I'm just
standing on my trampoline alone by
myself in my office I want this message
to reach millions of people
that's that's the intention that's when
I wake up I got my oldies playing and
then I'm looking at my calendar say this
is how I want to show up most days I
don't remember what day it is when I
wake up I I had no idea that today was a
Tuesday when I woke up
I put on my oldies I look at the
intention
ready to go that does not have to take a
long time this doesn't have to be a two
hour morning routine
you're you could be great at it
you're just not going through the actual
exercise to ask yourself how do I want
to show up today
so look at your calendars it's a good
exercise think of what's coming up in
your calendar today what's coming up for
the rest of the day before you go to
sleep how do you want to show up
how do you want to show up in your
business or at your work how do you want
to show up for the people that you work
with how do you want to show up for your
family how do you want to show up
because when you set that morning
routine right step one create a powerful
morning routine that makes you feel bold
confident powerful alive belief in self
and two as a part of that having the
intention for how you want to show up
imagine if every day for the next year
you did just those two things
powerful morning routine that makes you
feel bold powerful courageous right and
two you send an intention every morning
of how you want to live today
that you achieve it perfectly or not but
you did that every morning imagine how
much different your life is one year
from today
just by doing those two things
it's transformative
and then step number three is
in between
the activities during the day
remember your intention I have a
background on my cell phone it says
remember your intention so anytime I
look at my cell phone it's remember my
intention remember your intention
remember your intent what was my
intention this morning belief I got it I
want to spend more but I want to make
amazing YouTube content amazing videos
for you guys believe Nation remember the
intention because no matter what
happened in the morning you might forget
it come noon come two o'clock come four
o'clock come six o'clock you need the
reminder
of your intention so have it on my cell
phone background the other thing that I
do is I will book things in 25 or 55
minute increments
so if I'm filming blocks of content if
I'm doing meetings with people if I'm
doing uh training events or seminars
there's always a five minute break
from when I stop one activity to when I
start the next activity
and one reason for that is just to make
sure there's any technical issues or one
thing runs late or Etc I have a little
bit of a buffer but the more important
issue is that it allows me that little
window to reset the intention for the
next thing so especially if you're
switching tasks you're coming home from
work and you're going you're going home
and you're gonna you're gonna see your
spouse you're gonna see your kids or
you're switching from one meeting to a
next you're switching from a meeting to
making a video or switching from video
to write your book you're switching
between tasks give yourself a little
five minute window to just remember the
intention again
it totally changes how you show up as a
human
if you are going from work to home even
if that's I'm I'm I my studio here is in
my home right even if I'm going from
here to outside the door
laughs
if I give myself a five minute break
in between activities from stopping
filming to then going to hanging out
with my wife
and I asked myself remember your
intention what was your intention for
today
okay belief how do I bring that to Nina
how do I bring that to my relationship
even though I've just made all these
videos and my head's going a mile a
minute and I'm so excited for all the
content that we're producing and making
and launching amazing
how do I now show up for my relationship
just that five minutes it doesn't even
have to take five minutes but just
asking the question
resets the priorities
takes you off of living on autopilot and
living in intention
it changes how I show up to when I'm
gonna go out and hang out with Nina
so do those things your life will
dramatically change powerful morning
routine
set your intention every morning
and then have little breaks to remind
yourself of what that intention was
throughout the day
whether it's your cell phone background
whether it's five minute breaks in
between switching tasks
if you can decide
that you want to stop living in
accidental life stop living a
reactionary life based off of other
people's priorities for your time
controlling your agenda
put up a little bit of defenses and
walls to say no this is my time this is
my life
I'm gonna start living it with intention
you do that
Everything Changes I promise you eighty
percent of our inner dialogue is
negative and 95 of those thoughts are
the same thoughts that we had yesterday
that's what Beth Handel taught me she's
garyvee's life coach we had an awesome
session together and it really hit home
imagine that 80 percent of the thoughts
that you've got 80 percent
are negative we are beating ourselves up
we are telling ourselves that we can't
do things it's not even our friends and
family people around us telling us that
we suck it's us it's ourselves we tell
ourselves we're not good enough we can't
do this we're not strong enough smart
enough we're from the wrong country we
look the wrong way you know we're too
young we're too old whatever it is 80 of
our thoughts are negative and then 95 of
those negative thoughts are the exact
same negative thoughts that we had
yesterday it's no wonder why we stay
small it's no wonder why we stay stuck
because we've created this reinforcing
Loop of negativity this is why I think
the world's biggest problem is lack of
belief okay I'm I'm on a mission every
day wake up try to make content try to
spread the message to help people
believe in themselves more I think lack
of belief is the single biggest problem
in the world
and I also believe that everybody has
Michael Jordan level genius as something
like you are the greatest you're the
greatest in the world at something and
it's not what you went to school for and
it's not what your parents did for a
living probably it's something
completely different and you have to
have the courage to go off and Chase it
and find it and and do it because
the woman who solves cancer should have
already solved it by now but she never
believed in herself enough to go to
medical school and now she's a manager
and accounting firm which doesn't like
her life right I mean this is this is
where most of us are stuck most people
wake up and they drive the job that that
we don't like most people are stuck and
barely hanging on and do not like their
life and feel like they're not
contributing they're not they're not
making any kind of difference they're
not doing anything meaningful or
impactful at all in the world that's
most people imagine waking up and that's
your daily reality that may be you
or that may have been who you were you
still describe it and trying to improve
and get better but if 80 of those
thoughts that come through your head
conscious or unconscious are negative I
think a lot of conscious thoughts are
negative too
not just the subconscious the conscious
thoughts are negative you telling
yourself that you can't do something and
you're not good enough and then 95 are
the same as yesterday that we've just
created this this Loop this negative
thinking Loop so how do we break it how
do we break free how do we solve that
problem well that's that's the billion
dollar question and that's what I wake
up
every day trying to fix and I can give
you a couple things that I've worked on
and I've found helpful and hopefully
helps move the needle they don't have
all the answers but but some of these
might help the first one is to change
your environment the environment makes
such a huge difference for who you are
and your daily habits and what you
believe about yourself and the
environment is not just the people who
are around you although that definitely
helps you know if you've got negative
friends or family around you you want to
eliminate them completely or spend a lot
less time with them because it's really
really really hard to have a beautiful
plant grow when it's just you know toxic
waste being poured on top of them doable
but really really difficult and so
changing that can really help and
one of the best ways I found to do it is
content
it's content it's why I make so much
content for these channels that
hopefully
you wake up today and there's a piece of
content there waiting for you whether
it's me or showcasing somebody else
across all my channels or making
multiple pieces of content every single
day to try to hit it in the right way
maybe today's message with the right
voice is the one that makes a difference
for you and if you can shift
the amount of entertainment you're doing
or just shutting off the world some of
the content that you consume just helps
you shut off the world and Escape versus
educational content that helps you learn
improve get better and solve the problem
right entertainment is let's forget
about the problem and just laugh at
something else
education is let's learn to actually fix
the problem that is happening in our
life right I want to lean in on that a
lot more it doesn't mean that
entertainment doesn't exist in your life
it's not only education but if you can
shift the needle towards education to be
around the people who inspire you even
if you've never met them
it can really move the needle for your
your inner dialogue and your
self-confidence so the thing that saved
me in my first business in doing this
was modeling Bill Gates or Microsoft
when I I quit on my business partner I
struggled I didn't know you know I felt
worthless nothing was working I was
working every day and just no results in
in looking at Bill Gates's story that
that changed my life it saved my
business it allowed me to keep going
because now I had a little bit of hope
that Bill Gates could do it maybe I
could too and the more you surround
yourself with those people
the more you'll feel like you can do it
too so do an audit how many people in
your life the the actual humans that you
know and also just the people that you
subscribe to that you follow how many of
them make you feel better about yourself
and for too many people it's it's not
enough you know it's it's look at who
you follow on YouTube look at who
subscribed to
um look at who you're connecting with on
Instagram you know if you're loading
your phone you're going through
Instagram or you're watching YouTube
videos how many times have you gone
through it and all of a sudden an hour
has gone by and you were mindlessly
watching videos or even worse make you
feel worse about yourself you ever felt
that you watch a video and then you feel
worse about yourself afterwards or
you're following somebody and it makes
you feel worse about yourself you have a
choice to unfollow those people this is
not Instagram's fault or YouTube's fault
you can take accountability here you
have a choice to unfollow those people
and then a choice to follow the people
who make you feel better about yourself
that's my aim with all these videos I
want to leave you with strategies but
also more belief in yourself at the end
of every video and if I do that I
awesome you want more belief in your
life come back you know another shot of
espresso tomorrow morning we're here and
if I don't do that cool thank you for
giving it a shot and and don't quit on
that go find somebody else who gives you
the motivation inspiration that you need
and so you can make a conscious choice
because it's so easy to stay stuck it's
so easy to stay small it's so easy to to
be the one that pours in other people
and not have anybody pour into us and
you need to make a conscious choice to
to raise your environment to change your
environment and it doesn't mean you have
to go move to a different country or
move to a fancier house or anything else
you start by just changing who you
associate with even at a mass scale
right
I've learned a lot from Steve Jobs I've
been inspired by Oprah Winfrey my
favorite entrepreneur of all time was AP
giannini who started Bank of America
these are people who I've never met
you know and and in the case of jobs in
Janine I never you know will meet
because they've passed
but I've been inspired by them and
they've made me better and they've
taught me and I've learned from them and
they've inspired me and I get courage
from them
because I've consumed their content
and you can do that too
it's just being intentional about it so
that when you raise your environment you
raise your life
the second thing is try not to do it
alone
it's really hard to go after
a goal to change your mindset to
accomplish big things when you're doing
it all by yourself you know
it this is why a lot of people quit
because you might have one one amazing
day or you watch The Right video you
have the right experience and it's like
that I wanna this is this is the life I
want you ever had that right like this
is the life that I want this is who I
want to be this is this is where I could
go you have a glimpse of a potential
future that you could be it's like I
want that and and you actually feel in
your heart that you can be that you can
accomplish that right has that happen to
you and then what happens the next day
you wake up and it's kind of gone and
then the next day it's completely gone
and then you're back to your old life
and the limiting beliefs and the habits
and and you know you gain back the 20
pounds and like how did I end up back
here I thought I fixed this right does
that ever happen to you
a lot of it is because you're doing it
alone
and this took me a long time to figure
out
as an introverted person as a shy person
as somebody who doesn't like asking for
help
um
as someone who's afraid of disappointing
people
being a part of a community
is not
it just sounds super scary to me
we just did our seven day challenge for
built to serve and a bunch of people
join movement makers uh we had almost
100 people join Movie Makers at the end
of it and it's people who want to be
thought leaders and want to be speakers
and authors and coaches and course
creators and membership creators and all
of the stuff there's a big impact that
spread your message and I was giving
people
a lot of uh
not just encouragement but respect like
the people who ended up joining
I just had incredible respect for
because I wouldn't have done it if I go
back to 19 year old Evan when I started
my first business I wouldn't have done
it I wouldn't have had the courage to do
it I wouldn't have joined the group we
had people sharing their videos like
tell us about your your who your why
your how is your this methodology from
the book but make a video you know
sharing your purpose and your biggest
pain of all time and some of these you
know kind of deep uh things that you
have to record and share and I mean it
was optional not everybody did it but in
doing that
for a lot of people it was their first
video that they've ever done
for a lot of people it's the first time
they've even shared their story to
anybody that they were sharing things in
the group that they hadn't told their
spouse
you know or their family or their best
friend and now they're making a video
in their car
sharing their story
and you see them become liberated you
see them you see them start super scared
and Afraid and unsure and fixing their
hair and you know apologizing for the
lighting not being good and them being
in the car and not knowing what they're
doing to then just seeing the
transformation of somebody
going through the Cocoon you know being
a caterpillar and turn into a butterfly
and sharing their story for the first
time and I was in awe because I I
couldn't imagine me doing that at 19
when I started my first business
I was too afraid to join a community I
was too afraid of being judged
I was too afraid of being not good
enough
and that kept me small
I kept my growth really slow
fortunately I kept going you know if
you've seen my my
chart on my website where I show how
much I've grown every year over year
over year over year where I've been took
five years to get the 7 000 subscribers
or something like that
and I just kept going and the one thing
that I've got was just tenacity and
drive and I will just keep going in the
face of adversity but I made it just
incredibly hard on myself being alone
not being open to sharing with my
friends what I was struggling with and
never joining the community
so I think that can really help you you
know I think I think trying to go and
change your mindset and accomplish big
things that nobody around you has done
yet and there are some days that you
feel incredibly inspired and motivated
and Powerful like yeah I can do this but
you're probably not living there most of
the time
what if you did or what if you lived
kind of close to that most of the time
and point number one of raising your
environment can definitely help
but Point number two is just don't try
to do it alone
even if it's one person you don't have
to join movement makers you don't have
to join a group
but even just one person
one person who you can talk to you can
connect with
who you can you know share your stories
with not just complain to not not talk
about how hard everything is and just
have somebody to vent to but somebody
who supports you
if you had a group of people who
supported you
well you felt welcome we felt like you
weren't alone in this journey we felt
like people understood you
and we're actually genuinely cheering
you on to go you know become the person
that you want to be
Everything Changes
so raise your environment
get a community
and watch your impact happen great ideas
flow through you teach yourself to learn
to understand to feel that great ideas
flow through you that when you are
feeling bold powerful courageous
ambitious an idea comes to you that is
the right perfect idea for you right now
and don't let your head talk you down
from doing it I think most of us live
small I think I think we're constantly
living small we're so concerned about
our friends telling us that our ideas
suck it's us
it's ourselves it's you telling yourself
that your idea sucks that you can never
do that we feel great one day this is
the entrepreneur roller coaster right
you feel great one day oh my God this is
such a great idea I could go do this
this is amazing and maybe you start
taking some action on it but then what
immediately happens is your head starts
taking over say well you I mean you
can't do that because you you don't have
the school the education the parents the
connections you live in the wrong
country you're the wrong gender race Etc
and then and then it stops
meanwhile dummies are winning off of
your idea with less heart with less
drive with less ambition with less of a
desire to do good they're winning off of
your idea because they went off and did
something while you are stuck
overthinking your idea this is what we
do this is what entrepreneurs especially
the the heart
centered ones do
stock constantly over analyzing
overthinking and stuck in the mud
instead of actually creating and the way
to go through it is to trust in your
ideas
if you're concerned that that's too
egotistical like oh I'm so great I got
these great ideas great take yourself
out of the equation
trust that the idea came from somewhere
and it was given to you
and it's your responsibility to birth it
into life it's not even your idea it was
given to you
and then go off and create
one of the things that has really helped
me achieve speed and momentum is
I've learned to not judge the ideas that
come to me
I've just said you know what because I
came up with this idea now I have to go
do something about it and sometimes it
turns into the next great thing and
sometimes it goes nowhere that's okay
right the first top 10 video I ever made
on my channel was on Kanye West and he's
behind me on the wall there he is Kanye
West
because my friend
made a blog post about Kanye uh that was
in a negative light and so I wanted to
make it
positive so hey you can learn from him
and so I made a top 10 video on Kanye
West just to show my friend I had other
things planned today shut that all down
just to make this one video just to show
my friend with no plan of this is gonna
be my next big idea right people say
well how did you know I didn't know I
got an idea and I did something about it
I'm not that smart to be able to project
10 years forward and say Here's Where
the world is going right maybe I can
leave that to Elon Musk I'm not that
smart
but it came to me so I did it and it
turned into something amazing
I've had other ideas that that I started
and didn't go anywhere either the idea
wasn't good enough or or more likely my
energy just kind of faded from it and so
I stopped doing it but at least I gave
it a shot all of these ideas that you've
got you don't know which one's gonna
work out they could all be practically
speaking great ideas what's the best
idea for you I don't know you don't know
either until you start to try it
by taking the immediate action on it
you have to trust in your ideas that
they came to you for a reason are you
supposed to do something about them
so how do we start doing how do you
start taking the action how do you start
getting getting St unstuck in your head
of all the stuff that holds us back from
actually creating let me give you some
steps step number one
idea to action
take your brain out of the equation
there's a phrase that when when you're
in your head you're dead like as soon as
you start overthinking something it's
over
you came up with the idea you're gonna
do something about it when today
you came with the idea so you're gonna
do something about it when right now
what's your next idea what are you
thinking of right to go do something
about it immediate action take the
because you came up with the idea
therefore you must go do the thing
that's the training you want to give
yourself doesn't mean you have to go and
do some big thing but you have to get
started immediate momentum you want to
start a YouTube channel great you pull
out your phone and you make a video it
doesn't matter what you say it doesn't
matter what the lighting is don't worry
about the sound don't worry about having
a fancy microphone or fancy camera you
pull out your phone you press record and
you say you're starting the channel and
you post that first video
okay but then it's gonna suck great
which leads to point number two expect
to suck at the beginning
why do you expect to be great out of the
gate you will not be great out of the
gate doesn't mean that you suck as a
human just means that your product sucks
but it's your first attempt that's okay
when you try anything you fall when you
get on a bicycle you didn't just ride
right you get a skateboard you didn't
just go
you're gonna suck that's okay that's the
learning process you're gonna learn a
lot more and get better a lot quicker by
actually trying where we're stuck in
learning and researching and planning
and then nothing ends up getting created
you are wasting your best energy on
planning this is what most this is what
most people do this is what happens
almost all the time you can with an idea
I think it's a great idea
oh my gosh it's such a great idea great
you spend the next day or until you go
to sleep planning researching preparing
and then you wake up tomorrow and say I
can't do that that's crazy that idea I
had yesterday is crazy I can't do that
who did I think I was to be able to do
that you spent your best energy your
most confident energy your most bold
energy on doing the wrong thing planning
instead of making planning is important
but it's not the first thing you should
do the first thing you do is take some
kind of action some kind of immediate
momentum some kind of commitment
especially to somebody else that you're
going to do something
so if you want to start a YouTube
channel you take out your phone and say
hi I'm going to start my YouTube channel
I don't know what I'm going to make
content of I'm really nervous but I've
been putting this off for five years and
I'm tired of putting things off so I
don't know join my journey and let's see
how it goes
great post
and as you start making
you're gonna get better at it your first
thing is supposed to suck if you're
going to get started you're going to
start making YouTube videos as an
example and your first video is amazing
then you actually suck then you waited
too long your first version of whatever
you do should be terrible that's okay
so Step One is listen to the ideas trust
the ideas they are right for you because
they came to you you got to do something
about it take immediate action
and in Step number two is expect to suck
reduce the burden of expectation on
yourself that you have to be great from
the start as kids we do this right we
start we try we fail we laugh hahaha and
as adults all of a sudden we're afraid
to do anything
and what you do is just slide into more
of your comfort zone and more your
comfort zone more of your comfort zone
more of your comfort zone and then
realize why do I hate my life so much
because you're doing the same thing
every day because you're afraid to
Branch out a little bit
just expect to suck
reduce that burden that you have to be
amazing
and if you keep practicing you keep
loving it you keep building it guess
what you're gonna get great at it
doesn't have to take a decade this hacks
his shortcuts model success you'll get
there faster
but you still have to do the journey and
step one of the journey is the most
important step and is also the most
painful step that it's gonna suck
amazing every time you suck at something
at the start pat yourself on the back
you did a good job
step number three
and this is just the caveat is pay
attention to your energy when you come
up with ideas okay I'm assuming you're
in a positive bold ambitious confident
courageous State when you are feeling a
positive emotion the ideas that flow
through you are the right ideas for you
however when you're feeling negative low
you're feeling judgmental you're feeling
anger you're feeling depression you're
feeling rage you're you're upset that
somebody else is having success when
you're in a negative mindset
the ideas that come to you are not the
one ones for you those are the ones to
sit on right like I'm gonna show her I'm
gonna I'm gonna do this thing to him I'm
gonna I'm gonna get my Revenge by doing
that okay let those are the ideas to sit
on and it's funny because those are the
ideas we usually act on
the spontaneous ideas that come to you
that are negative you're more likely to
act on than the spontaneous ones that
come to you that are positive
you're more likely to send that nasty
text or leave that negative review or do
that negative thing instead of the
positive one and so if you're in a
negative state of mind that's when it's
worth waiting till tomorrow you know if
tomorrow you think it's the right call
okay then then let's think about it but
not in the moment don't do the negative
ones in the moment
but if it's positive if you just came
back from a seminar or you're watching
this video or you're around amazing
humans and you get these great ideas
those are the ones that you need to take
some immediate action on
you have amazing ideas
you have a a heart and a soul that wants
a serve that wants to help that wants to
contribute that wants to not just fill
your pockets and fill your bank account
but also contribute and help other
people you know you've got something
much bigger inside you
but it does not come out
unless you start to listen to those
ideas and start to do something about
them
so the next time an idea comes to you
maybe you got one right now maybe
something's flowing through you right
now
learn to trust that idea tell yourself
that great ideas flow through you
that you need to take some immediate
action on it and that it's gonna suck at
the beginning and that's the best and
that's how you learn
because if you kept doing that do that
for three months do that for six months
do that for 12 months the amount of
amazing things you're going to help
create for yourself for your family for
your community for the world
is going to be just outstanding and I
can't wait to see what you end up making
so I have a slightly different take on
meditation and if you've been struggling
with meditation in your life this might
help I first thought believe in the
power of meditation I believe the
science I believe all the studies and I
used to judge myself and feel really bad
about it because I I felt like I
couldn't meditate I would sit there on
the couch or on the pillow or on the bed
or lie down and I never felt anything
when I was meditated I could sit and I
could be present and I could I could I
could do it and then and I could sit
there for 20 minutes and it felt like 20
minutes
but I never felt any different I mean
that was where it started to shift for
me is not that I didn't feel anything in
the moment but never felt any different
coming out and I've meditated with some
of the
the the best meditation teachers
um on the planet and it's never really
led to an impact for me uh in the moment
or afterwards or sustained and I again
would judge myself really harsh like hey
I mean how I want to make this work how
do I make this work I Believe In The
Sciences go and make it work
what I've distilled it down to is into
two parts one is a lot of meditation a
lot of benefits I believe in meditation
are really just about being present and
being Mindful and that is something that
I can do a lot more naturally than maybe
most people and I don't find a lot of
benefit in it because I'm more there
than not so I I'm 85 present 15 future
focused and zero percent pass focus when
you are thinking about the past it's
usually really negative way sometimes we
like pass Look Backwards into the past
and it's gratitude and and remembering
great memories and
um you know looking all the great things
we've done but for the most part when
you look backwards it's negative it's
regrets it's I wish I did this or why
did that person do that to me I wish I
had said something different we're we're
looking negatively on our past mostly
through the lens of regret and what you
did or what other people did and when
you're looking forward entrepreneurs
love looking forward and the vision and
the building and what you can create and
all the amazing things but a lot of
looking forward is also uncertainty and
stress and anxiety in what may happen
and what could happen and what might
happen if x happens and just we're stuck
in these negative Loops a lot of the
backwards thinking is negative through
the lens of regret and a lot of the
Forward Thinking is negative through the
lens of anxiety stress and worry and so
that's where hey if you're
present-minded you're going to be a lot
happier you're going to be a lot more
focused right if you're just thinking
about what you should have done or what
might happen to you you're not actually
able to be productive and get stuff out
right now in the present and so the the
job becomes how do I stay present and I
think a lot of that is accomplished
through meditation for most people if
you're if you're in a state of stress
thinking about the regret of the past or
anxiety about the future I think
meditation can be incredibly helpful to
help you get back to present even just
focusing on your breath breathe in
breathe out even something as simple as
that can help calm you down and get you
back to the present moment which then
allows you to
be able to be productive uh solve the
problem be happy because you're being
more present so for me that's actually
quite easy I'm in the present uh a lot
more than anywhere else and I used to
think it as a negative a friend of mine
used to make fun of me for having a bad
memory it's like you're such a bad
memory it's like and I later realized I
I don't have a bad memory I I want to
remember what's important to me but two
I'm not living in the past like I don't
care about what happened I'm looking at
right now today I don't know what day it
is I don't know what day it is I don't
know I I know it's 2022 when recording
this I'd have to think about what month
it is
I don't know what I'm doing after
recording this video I don't know what I
did yesterday I don't know what I'm
doing tomorrow let alone once I press
stop on this video I am here with you
this is this is my entire attention is
making this video right now that's it
this is this is the present moment for
me and what I've discovered is
this is meditation
at least the the portion of it where
you're getting back to present moment if
that's one of the main benefits of
meditation then this is meditation for
me I'm only in the present moment right
now being here talking with you guys and
that's it
and I realized that most of my life is
lived like that yes I love planning for
where I'm gonna go but most of my time
isn't spent in planning it's in and
executing in doing and I have to look at
my calendar to see what I'm doing
tomorrow or what I'm doing when somebody
asks me on a Wednesday what's your
weekend gonna look like
weekend I don't even know what I'm doing
in the next hour let alone what I'm
doing this weekend and when people ask
me on a Monday how was your weekend like
I don't know
that was that was that was yesterday
that was two days ago I'm I got stuff to
do right now I'm working on my life
right now and and not just work even
just enjoying even just life even just
me spending time with with my wife or my
son or on a trip it's like let's enjoy
this moment where we're at right now and
so if that's you I would introduce the
idea of hey that's a different
perspective shift like maybe you are
meditating right now and you might be
over judging yourself because if you're
in the present that's one of the biggest
benefits one of my favorite things to do
every morning is I go on a belief walk
and I found when a lot of people would
say oh I get my best ideas when I'm
meditate it if I get creative
breakthroughs when I'm meditating part
of that that I believe is hey you've
unblocked yourself from the past and the
future the regrets of the past the
stress of the future to get back to
present which then calms you down to
then that should be more creative and
solve the problem I found I wasn't
getting I wasn't really getting answers
I wasn't getting Solutions I wasn't
being very creative of sitting down
lying down and having my body be still
where I get a lot more of my energy and
creativity and ideas when I'm moving so
I get a lot of ideas
when I'm walking so I do a believe walk
every morning which is 30 to 60 minutes
I'll take the dogs out and then I'll go
for a walk usually the Tim Hortons grab
myself a coffee Canadian coffee brain
here and
No Agenda just think about what what am
I doing today you know what what day is
it what I want to accomplish today uh
taking some fresh air get a fresh
perspective and the the act of moving I
find gets my creativity flowing a lot
more I get ideas in the shower you know
when I'm when I'm moving have you got
ideas in a shower I think that's
meditation maybe it's a different
version of it a different definition of
it but I think that's meditation where
you can calm down when you can focus on
present and you get some great ideas to
come I'm selling my place we just bought
a new house we're selling this place and
the studio looks a little different
normally I'm filming in my car because
we're running some errands or my regular
studio and to get this place ready to
sell you you know we wanted to have a a
place that everybody could connect to
and so what my agent did was make an
office in a different room and I'm
sitting down and I have not sat down for
two years I don't know my last time I
like sat down to actually work and and
you might even notice me like I'm
Shuffling around a little bit like I
like to move normally I'm on a
trampoline and I'm bouncing 20 to 40 000
times a day and I got that because I
would find that when I did phone calls I
would much rather stand up and walk
around the office than just sit down and
so I'm a lot more creative and have a
lot more energy when I'm moving and
maybe that movement in my energy creates
movement in you know brain energy and
capacity and thinking creativity as well
but all of that is my form of meditation
and so anytime that I would challenge
you to at least consider the fact that
anytime that you're present
any time that you are focused on
something that you can consider that
part of the benefits of meditation
the second part of meditation that I
haven't fully connected to yet and I
don't have a solution for yet is when
you access theta waves and that's
basically when you're bouncing between
conscious and subconscious and where you
feel like
time flies so for me when I sit down or
lie down doing a meditation
if it's 20 minutes it feels like 20
minutes and I don't think I'm hitting
any Theta levels
um I can sit there and be present and
focus on my breath or you know I've
chewed a cookie for half an hour or an
hour and never swallowed it you know
like the focus and the presence I can do
but it still feels like it's 20 minutes
or half an hour or an hour I've never
had a I sat down for an hour and I felt
like it was I was only on for five
minutes
I get that more through the work that
I'm doing I get that more
um I recently did a six hour uh q a with
Tom bilyu's impact community
on his Discord and
I was six hours I didn't go to the
bathroom I didn't take a break I was I
was reading the questions and answering
the questions my throat was burning
didn't even notice it till the end and
had that six hours flew where that felt
if you asked me how long was it I would
have said I don't know it was like 20
minutes half an hour like six hours six
hours later still going and then we
eventually wrapped it up because I need
to go to dinner
my wife where I said yeah I'm gonna do
this short little q a and turned out to
be six hours
so maybe that's even a better form of
meditation maybe maybe when you're in
your purpose and doing great work and
time flies because you're having fun
maybe that is a better form of
meditation for you if you struggle with
just sitting down and meditating maybe
doing that work is healing you know I
think a lot of people meditate to heal
and I think of a part of why that could
work is because you're again removing
the stress of the past of the regret of
the past and removing the anxiety and
stress of the future and when your
body's all stressed out it's not going
to heal right but when you can get back
to present and remove the stress you
create the conditions for healing in
your body
well I remember when I broke my neck in
2019 and I kept doing my tour I kept
staying on it because I wanted to be
around entrepreneurs I wanted to keep
doing the I could have canceled the tour
wouldn't have been a big deal but that
became healing for me in feeling like I
was serving that I was helping sitting
at the front of a room for four hours
with
immobilized neck brace on ice packs you
know on my neck two or three pillows
behind me I couldn't move for four hours
but just talk
that became healing for me
and so
at least what's helped me for where I'm
at right now I'm totally open to to new
experiences and being changed and you
know swaying my opinion before I'm at
right now
staying present
and doing
not just the work but doing activities
that you enjoy that you feel are in
service to others that you feel like
you're living your purpose that you feel
like you're having an impact think about
the things that you love doing where
where hours get lost I'm not talking
about like opening your phone and
scrolling through Instagram when you
realize that two hours have passed and
like how did I just waste all this time
not that but
in service of others and helping to see
him moving around right now I gotta move
I can't sit still
I don't like it when I get in creative
ideas I gotta move I play with my ring
you know they got the ring is all over
the place it's not just on my finger
this this gives me more creativity like
the motion creates more creativity for
me
and so if you find those things where
you love doing it's in service to others
is helping people time gets lost and you
feel it in your heart and your soul that
this is the right thing for you to be
doing for where you're at right now
that maybe that's you know maybe just
maybe that's the form of meditation that
you need the most
that
by staying present and helping others
and being in service maybe that's all
the healing that you need
maybe that is the present mind that you
need maybe that is the focus that you
need maybe that is the meditation that
you're already doing
and if that gives you some extra
perspective or a different view on
meditation than what you might hear
other places I hope that helps maybe
judge yourself a little bit less or
maybe lean into something that you
thought didn't exist because it's
certainly played a huge impact on my
life and thank you for allowing me to
share this story with you you are
staying small because you are afraid
you're afraid of the worst case scenario
coming true losing having no money and
being embarrassed but you know you're
capable of more you know the way that
you're going about doing things right
now is nothing compared to what you're
capable of unless you lose that scarcity
mindset you're always going to stay
small knowing that you are capable of
more today I'm going to show you how so
one of the easiest ways to get out of
your scarcity mindset is to go from idea
to action as soon as you get an idea you
do something about it and sometimes that
idea often that idea is going to be too
big too scary too crazy you can't do it
who are you to do this you don't have
the money resources time connections
energy right all of that all of the
excuses that come into your head I like
to teach myself that as soon as I get an
idea I go do something
it may not work but you have genius
ideas trust them go do something so this
is great this is a grant video because
when I did my tour in 2019 that's
January to April we hit 23 different
cities over 90 days and at the beginning
I was trying to find different sponsors
that would help out with travel
accommodations because it was me Nina my
film guy Danny and and all of our gear
was mostly Danny's gear
lighting and we had speakers and camera
gear and all of this stuff and we ended
up renting a suburban and driving across
America but before doing that I emailed
Grant and I said hey Grant
uh
can I use your plane for 90 days
for my tour
and to his credit
the email that he wrote back was what's
the upside not no not forget about it
not do you know how much it cost and
just jet fuel and and you know my pilot
and then I can't use my plane for three
months he said what's the upside I said
well listen I'm gonna let everybody in
my audience know about you and listen we
didn't get a deal we didn't make it
happen but it's that it's that idea of
going for my data action
right and I still do a lot with Grant
right making this video helping promote
all the stuff that he's up to we're
looking at doing something together when
I go to Miami next
and so that one exchange didn't ruin the
relationship and I'm happy to share it
publicly
maybe that's embarrassing for some
people right but the idea of trusting
your ideas you get an idea you go do
something it may be too big and maybe it
may be scary you might have people say
no even if the most likely answer is no
right the most likely answer might be no
the most likely answer to me asking
grant that question is no right it's a
no but if I don't ask it's a no 100
don't take the no away from somebody
else
it might be 99.999 now but there's still
a little chance maybe this is Yes
somewhere in there trust your ideas do
something I did and so continue to do
and that's how you escape scarcity
mindset that's how you escape playing
small and actually go down and Chase the
life that you want to live so let's get
more specific I'm going to give you a
three-step process that I think will
help step number one is idea to action
so as soon as you get that idea you
don't judge it you don't think about it
you don't say why me you just go and you
do something find the smallest possible
way to just get started right so you
just trust that the idea came to you I
believe that ideas flow through you you
got that idea for a reason why are you
thinking about it don't worry about why
you're thinking about it just go do
something about it find the smallest
possible way to just go do something
about it you are a genius therefore you
come up with genius ideas not all of
them work out maybe the timing was wrong
maybe the execution was wrong but it's
still a great idea because you came up
with it therefore it is a great idea and
you have to go do something about it so
trust your ideas and go from idea action
step number two is what I call the two
percent difference here's what happens
most of the time when people come up
with an idea you default into planning
mode planning strategy thinking
researching and then you wake up the
next day and you're back to square one
you're back to normal like the energy
that you got the boldness the courage
that you had is gone because you woke up
the next day
so you've wasted your best time your
best momentum that Peak in energy on
planning where what I want you to do is
use that for Action so the two percent
difference is instead of planning to get
to 100 which is what most of us will do
you come up with an idea then plan how
it's going to happen 100 to finish line
so you know what the finish line is
going to be stop thinking you even know
where it's going to be instead of
worrying about 100 focus on the first
two percent
the first two percent I have this idea
what can I do right now right now that
will get me two percent of the way right
you wanna you wanna make a YouTube video
great pull out your phone start
recording that's two percent you want to
remind yourself to breathe this is one
thing we have on our on our door every
time I leave the door every time I leave
my condo there's a sign that says
breathe right because I want to remind
myself to breathe take take practice my
Wim Hof take 30 breaths in in and out as
I walk outside my condo every time
I put that there was a as a play bigger
trigger for myself but it's easy to
think well if I'm gonna put a sign on my
door then I need it to be a certain size
and I need to be the perfect picture and
I need it to be framed and you make it
bigger and then you don't do anything
that's the biggest problem you just
don't have momentum you're not doing
enough
and so step number one the two percent
difference is
I took out a sticky note and I just
wrote breathe and I stuck it on my door
and it's a reminder every day to breathe
that doesn't mean that you can't go back
and plan doesn't mean that you can't
replace it with something nicer bigger
better yes of course planning has its
role but not as a first step your first
step is action if your first step is
planning you're losing
if your first step is planning that's
why you're a perfectionist that's why
you don't have momentum happening
against your ideas your first step
idea into the first two percent and then
step number three is tie yourself Worth
to the effort not the result this is
where again so many entrepreneurs will
fail because you tied your self-worth to
the outcome of you accomplishing that
thing if you woke up and you only did
things that you knew you're gonna win at
You're Gonna Play small for life you're
only doing things inside your comfort
zone because you know you're gonna win
at them right or a very high degree
chance you're gonna win if that's all
you ever take on you play small for life
but if you're going outside your comfort
zone taking on new projects growing as a
human learning getting better checking
on new challenges that are bigger and
Beyond you most days you're actually
going to wake up and fail because you're
doing something new
but if you woke up every day and were
proud of the effort you were putting in
you're proud of yourself for the effort
you put in your max effort you're trying
to make the best video you can you're
trying to make the best product or
service you can you're proud of yourself
for the effort every single day
you're going to create amazing things
Way Beyond what you thought you're
capable of and way more than the person
who just sits inside their bubble doing
things that they know they're going to
win it
tie yourself forth to the effort not the
results you know there's a great quote
um
find people or find someone in your life
not to grow old with but to stay young
with
you know and and that we can apply we
typically think about that as our
significant others but but those could
just be the people that are in your life
the people like you stay young by
watching Eric
you know like you get this you're still
on a parallel path like Eric and I are
on this parallel path right now with all
the you guys and maybe I never see Eric
again in my life or maybe we we start a
multi-billion dollar Venture Capital
fund together and change the world like
who knows right like you never know how
long I can feel a little path you'll be
on with somebody right
um but like be on the path of the people
who make you feel the way that you want
to feel that you can stay young with
that you can you can express yourself
that they're pushing you in a loving way
not another you need to go off and do
this Eric because you suck right like
everybody has an opinion on what we
should do with our lives and there's
some very rare people that we come
across them I like the expression I
collect good people that's what I like
to talk about collect good people when
you see someone that you like and it
makes you feel better about yourself
when you're around them find a way to
spend more time with them because they
will make a really really big difference
in your life and if you're listening to
this show you are probably the one
pouring into other people you know like
we're we're pouring into other people
you're the most optimistic person you
know you're the happiest person you know
you're the most ambitious person that
you know you're the most service-minded
person you know and that's awesome keep
pointing to others but who's pointing to
you
who's encouraging you who's sharing in a
loving way again like hey you could be
doing you could be doing so much more
like why don't we do this together and
when you find those people like collect
them hold on to them be around them more
because it'll make a huge huge
difference in your life people aren't
afraid of failing you're afraid of
failing in front of other people you'll
sing in the shower but you won't sing on
the street corner you'll record a video
but you'll never release it you'll be
your own biggest critic but you won't at
the same time also be your own biggest
fan that needs to change
starting today so my biggest fear is
disappointing people I'm terrified of
disappointing people the idea that you
would come to my thought Leadership
Academy and I would teach you how to win
on social media and get the ideas out of
your head and pay two thousand dollars
to do it the idea that that you would
come and be disappointed destroys me and
it's led to some positive things and
that I always over deliver I'm always
obsessed I'm always putting so much
value to that even if you only get 10 of
the value I'm given you still more than
made the money that you invested into
any of the stuff that I'm doing but at
the same time it's still this fear and
so I want to attack the fear I teach
myself to attack the fear and I think
you should too an example was when I did
my tour
90 days 23 cities and I I did a paid
tour because I was afraid to do it and
this is supposed to be a free Taurus it
was supposed to be coffee shop meetups
across the U.S low res super easy if one
person shows up great if nobody shows up
awesome if 100 people show up great
there's no risk right it's free you come
don't come whatever and my agent said
that's that's plain and small you got to
charge the event and my first reaction
was oh my God I can't charge this event
right like
choking up because I'm afraid because
I'm afraid that that if I start charging
for it then I need to I need to bring so
much more value
and because that was the reason that I
had to go off and do it if there was a
strategic reason why I should do a free
event then that that's fine my next tour
I'm looking at for 2020 is going to be
free is going to be ideally fingers
crossed I get my book deal it's going to
be at bookstores with my new book launch
so I want to do 20 something cities east
coast uh Texas Mexico with my book
launch and it's it's free to come
hopefully you buy a book but it's you
know not required but it's free to come
out because it's going to be supporting
the book launch that's a strategic
reason why I should be free I didn't
have a good reason why the first one
shouldn't be free what a tour this year
shouldn't be free and so I had to do it
I had to step into the fear you have to
step into the fear and do it because you
need to attack the thing that you're
afraid of especially when it's related
to other people right I'm not afraid of
failing I'm afraid of fail in front of
other people right I I can suck all day
here in the office but I don't want to
suck in front of somebody else I don't
want to make people feel like whether
they're spending 50 bucks to come and
see me that was on tour or 2 000 bucks
to come see me at my thought Lucia me
here I don't want people to feel
disappointed and because I feel that way
I need to step into it and I try to
teach myself attack it attack it attack
it if there's no good strategic reason
why then I have to do it because
otherwise I'm playing small and even
just attacking it for the sake of
attacking it is good
even if it doesn't lead to a positive
result for your business it's good
because you're building strength because
you're pushing your comfort zone because
you're getting better because you're
growing that's worth something that's a
ton of value because if you can conquer
your fear of doing this one thing that
translates to every of your life if you
teach yourself to have more courage that
translates everywhere
so maybe you're afraid of if you're on a
cruise ship and they bring up couples
and they do a game show you're afraid of
what might happen on that game do it
how does that make you a better
entrepreneur it makes you a thousand
times better as an entrepreneur because
that's the same fear that you face in
your business that fear of going on that
game show on the cruise ship that fear
of taking your phone and recording a
video in public on the street these
fears that seem like nothing they show
up everywhere in your life they show up
everywhere in your business
and so learning to tackle them
especially in low stakes
starts building the muscle who cares if
you fail on the street corner making a
video great go do it if that if that is
scaring you right now do it teach
yourself you do it you have courage you
do scary things
if you come on the other side you'll
come up with more strength and then
you'll start seeing things happen in
your business
you'll have more courage you'll have
more boldness you'll be more willing to
do things and then your business starts
taking off
you have to lose the fear of failing in
front of other people I'm going to give
you three ways on how to do it step
number one is embrace your bold ideas
I'm a big believer that when you have
these moments of boldness maybe it's
happening right now maybe you're feeling
bold right now watching the video
amazing you have these moments of
boldness we have moments of boldness
I don't think people are bold all day
long right and if you are then you have
moments of even greater boldness hear
these moments these spikes these hits
right you go to an event I'll get people
come to my thought Leadership Academy
they have these huge moments of boldness
right and then you fall back down
and that's normal you're watching a
movie you get inspired you fall back
down you have a conversation you get
inspired you fall back down the
decisions that you make in the moments
of boldness I believe are the right ones
for you those are the decisions you have
to follow through on an Embrace and then
your head talks you down from them the
head brings you back down the plane
small
and so when you're feeling bold what
have you come up with I want to go do X
you have to do it you have to start
building momentum you have to start
committing to some other people embrace
the Bold ideas recognize that those
aren't the crazy ideas those crazy ideas
that come up with your feelings are not
crazy those are actually the best ones
for you you're just buried under a pile
of garbage of limited beliefs on top of
you those are the things you have to go
chase down and when it gets hard when it
gets difficult when you want to quit
remind yourself this idea can do when I
was feeling bold I have to do it because
I do both things you teach yourself step
number two is expect to suck this is
where it gets super liberating expect to
suck the first time you do anything
expect to suck why do you expect to be
great the first time out what do you
expect your first video that you make to
be great it's not
it'll suck that's the best it should
suck right if you are if you are amazing
at making your first video then you
should have started making videos four
years ago I believe that you waited too
long your first at anything should be
terrible doesn't mean that you suck I
think you're amazing you're a genius
you're Michael Jordan you're the best of
all time it's something
but Michael Jordan didn't didn't dunk
his first ball right he didn't he didn't
shoot and it went in right away right
you suck at the beginning that's normal
learning any skill
want to be a basketball player you know
what a good basketball player looks like
if you want to be a YouTuber you know
what a good YouTube video looks like but
then you can't do it yet your first one
sucks and that's where most people quit
because they expect to be good they're
worried about looking bad in front of
the people they're not good the first
time out and so then they never go back
to it and this is what happens when when
people are are growing up you fail all
the time it's normal it's okay you fall
down awesome you get back up you keep
going and then we stop trying
as adults how often are you trying new
things how often are you willing to risk
failure to risk losing to risk looking
like a fool
you don't want to so you're not trying
as much anymore and you never find the
thing that you could be Michael Jordan
at you never find it and you get stuck
in some life and some job that you hate
forever that's most people I don't want
that to be you you need to try more you
need to explore more you need to expect
to suck the first 18 times of doing
something you may suck amazing keep
going the most important thing is are
you liking it do you like the process
successful people love the process I
love making videos I like this process
this fires me up I'm just sitting here
by myself in my office talking to a
camera I love it this is great I love it
for other people they may hate it
amazing don't do that go do something
else go go build little Teemo toys right
awesome whoever made this who made this
design in California oh they didn't even
they didn't give them credit all right
is that in California
right go make toys go do something go to
the thing that you love expect to suck
but if you love the process of it you
will get better
think about when you whatever you
learned in school most of it you forgot
this thing that you remember the stuff
that you connected with that you like
more so when you love something you're
going to just learn it a lot faster
when you like something you're going to
get better a lot faster even if you suck
at the beginning you'll get better a lot
faster you have to find that thing and
step number three is tie yourself forth
to the effort not the result what I want
you to do is go home and then sleep and
think am I proud of my effort am I proud
of what I did today am I proud of the
effort that I put in today I want to be
proud of my effort today in making
videos when I'm trying my best maybe
it's not good enough maybe today sucks
awesome but I'm trying I'm proud of my
effort I'm proud of the attempt most
people tie their software to winning to
the results to the money to the gold
medal to the to the whatever right to
the YouTube to the plaques back there
you can't do that because if you tie
your self-worth to winning
you're only going to do things that you
know you're going to win at
and therefore you play small for life if
you value winning above everything else
you'll only do the things that you know
you're going to win at and so you play
small for life you stop trying new
things because you're gonna fail at the
beginning right expect to suck you don't
expect to suck you expect to be great
and then you're not and so you stop
doing that thing you'll only take on
small projects but you can capable of
way more you keep doing something much
bigger
and so when you tie yourself forth to
the effort when you say I am proud of my
effort today
if you did that every day you're gonna
probably lose way more than most people
right you're going to be getting up and
losing almost every day and then you
have these big wins
but when you look back on this year of
losing you'll see holy cow how much have
I grown and you're actually winning way
more than most people way more than who
you used to be because you're proud of
your effort if you get up every day and
you're part of your effort
your life will change your business will
change like every day for the next year
do something that makes you proud of
your effort in your business in your
relationship proud of your effort you
tried your very best today
your life will be dramatically different
but it's because we're so focused on
winning you're so focused on the results
but then you you play small because you
don't want to risk losing you don't want
to risk failing you're on risk looking
like an idiot
if you want the life that you're after
Michael Jordan missed more shots than
most people
you're going to fail at most things most
my videos suck and don't go anywhere
but get up try again be proud of your
effort every single day
because you made it this far in a video
I want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you are special believe
Nation you made it here all the way to
the end and I love you so as a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments Below on this video
I will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome if you
want to watch another top 10 rules of
Evan Carmichael check out the video next
to me continue to believe I will see you
there finding your purpose finding your
passion finding what you're meant to do
is easy and I will beat this drum until
everybody figures it out because it's
one of the most common questions that I
keep getting asked we're not